hi everyone and welcome to this
community event I'm Silva a research
engineer at ug face and I've led the
team that develop theing face course and
we're very excited to release part two
of the course today with content that
should help you tackle any NLP task you
can check it out at
.c course and it's going to look like
this I'll Co today's event with leis
leis if you want to introduce yourself
sure good day everyone I'm leis and I'm
a machine learning engineer at hugging
face and I've been working with Silvan
and the team to build the content for
the course and uh today I'll be also
taking part in um introducing the
speakers with svan but before we
introduce the first Speaker today I'd
like to sort of show you a bit how we're
going to do the um the question and
answering so I'll share my screen and
you should see
the hugging face forums so um even
though you can probably see us on
YouTube or twitch we're going to take
all of the questions um on the Forum so
what you want to do um when you're
watching one of the speakers is you head
to the course um category and then here
you'll see um various uh topics for each
of the speakers so the first Speaker
today is going to be Tom molf and the
way it works is you um post a a reply to
this topic so you can say hello I have a
question and then once you post this
people can vote on that topic and we'll
then select um the most voted Topics by
when you click a like and this will then
allow us to rank the most important
questions that you have and it will also
let people who can't make it uh today
for the live stream also benefit from
all of your awesome
questions so with that I will head back
to
San so um our first Speaker today is
Thomas
wolf um Thomas wolf is a very own
co-founder and chief science officer at
ug face and top of creating many popular
libraries like Transformers and data
sets he is also the initiator and Senior
chair of the largest research
collaboration that has ever existed in
artificial intelligence called big hands
and today he will talk to us about
transfer learning and the birth of the
Transformers
Library so Tom ready when you
are thanks a lot
San okay hi everyone um today I'm very
happy to make a talk a little bit
different than what I do usually um
since you will learn a lot of things in
the in the coming course right this is
the this is a full week of classes a
full week of chapters to read so I
thought I won't do an educational course
like I do usually but I'll talk about
the origin of huging face and the origin
of Transformers the origin of all our
library and kind of walks you through uh
very personal uh honestly selection of
uh what happened in the past few years
at Hing face and in the field of
transfer
learning so let's go back uh in time uh
to the very beginning of why we're here
today at least why I'm here today which
is uh four years ago five years ago now
uh oober four uh Julia who was an old
classmate of of me we were making we
were playing music together in a kind of
progressive rock band um kind of talk to
me about the coming revolution of deep
learning and and say okay you you've
been knowing a little bit of science at
before before doing your your low degree
uh do you want to come back to doing s
science and I was like yeah actually
yeah and so we followed together uh this
Standford CS 224d deeply learning for
NLP class which was a lot about a lot
about
lstm uh skip thought vectors for those
who who were already following a little
bit and actually this is I think
interesting because today we kind of
back to this right we're doing a a
course at that time also we followed
that over the Internet there was still
no pandemic it was easier but still the
course was at Stanford we were both in
Europe and so maybe today uh some of you
will be following this class with
friends maybe friends in music gr band I
don't know H and maybe in a few years we
will have a very successful startup that
started today started this week by
following this course together and
that's really all that I hope for you I
think for us it's been an amazing an
amazing journey from this uh from this
day to to today and um the early days of
hugging face were actually quite
different than the Huggy face we know
today uh we were building a an AI my
chatbot that was a little bit like a to
talking
tagoi you could uh you could like
discuss of it it was the beginning of
generative Technologies right all with
lstm um and you could also send it
selfie there was beginning of image
classification to try to understand a
little bit what you were sending and to
try to reply with something fun and
that's how huging face started we were
just three four at this time um but
quite quickly we actually started to
open source a little bit of of code so
this is um this is a screenshot from the
hugging face GitHub
Pages four years ago uh you can see
probably libraries and framework you
don't know because they've changed a lot
but it was the first one we were really
proud of our
cerence uh pation of of an emoji
detector of like sentimental
detector but uh why has this all
completely change uh because there was a
couple of revolution in the field of NLP
uh a few years after we started so more
precisely around the beginning of 2018 I
would say so I think if you want to date
back this could maybe go back to this
first unsupervised sentiment
neuron paper from from Alec Radford
already at open AI where they trained an
lstm on uh the largest data set
that people had at the time which was
data set of Amazon
reviews where actually the internet was
already there but still not common
practice right to use that as a training
data set so they trained this lstm and
what they discovered is that the the
model the lstm learned to uh actually
categor to categorize
sentiment without being explicitly
taught to do that so this was trained in
a generative fashion this lstm was was
trained to generate the next token just
like we do today right um and they they
also identified well something that we
don't really use anymore today I would
say but some specific neurons that were
very uh finely tuned to detect
sentiment and so this was the first um
this was the first hint that
unsupervised pre-training with
generative objective could lead to good
performances on Downstream task like
santiment classification but this was
still uh using U lstm and the the data
set was still quite I would say dumb and
specific Amazon reviews are still not I
would say as widely
um as covering a wide field of NLP as
the DAT set that we have today so a bit
later uh I say at the end of
2017 so a few months later where where
the the first I think most impactful
paper which was this first Elmo which is
uh the the first um this this paper
called Deep contextualized
representation that was the Elmo the
beginning of the of the Muppet names
right for for all this model which kind
of show that if you pre-trained on kind
of a an lstm on on a wide wider
diversity of text so this one was
unfortunately using a shuffle text so it
only had like full sentence but not full
paragraph uh you could actually have
good performances on a lot of NLP task
and not only sentiment analysis but also
like question answering textual
entertainment and this kind of thing the
idea here was still kind of to extract
um token representation uh more than
maybe what we do today with like full
pre-train model and then really
concurrent to this work was the very
nice ULM Feit from Sebastian rder and
Jeremy Howard where they also pre-train
this
lstm and they also show that you could
adapt it to many many tasks so these two
paper really at the same time uh in the
beginning of 2018 people were like oh
maybe all this uh approach of transfer
learning that we've been using in
computer vision on image net for a long
time could be useful also in text and so
this kind of LED Sebastian to wrote this
this interesting piece in um around
summer
2018 which was maybe the image net
moment of NLP has arrived right and it
was very I think insightful in saying oh
pre-train language model can achieve
state-of-the-art results and that's
something that's going to change
everything
but this was just one part of the
Revolution which is transfer learning
pre-train model and the second part uh
was using Transformers in place from
from uh
lstm and here again uh I think Alec rfor
from aeni was really uh was really Pion
pioneering this by using the the GPT the
first GPT in 2018 so this was around the
summer uh with this generative
pre-trained
Transformers and actually the name
really GPT was I think only coined in
the following bird paper from Google
which was a few months later in October
a 2018 where I kind of use this same
Transformer model but instead of using
it as a as a coal or aive model they
used the now famous uh masked language
modeling objective right the noising the
noising objective and so these two paper
were very interesting because they mixed
this early idea of transfer learning
like having a model
pre-trained on a large data set with the
architectural Improvement of the
Transformer which made mostly the the
training very efficient a lot more
efficient than lstm though today we we
have like other well maybe we're coming
back I'm not sure this is maybe what
what you will be in charge to do if you
do research in this
film and uh what was the conclusion of
mixing these two objective well it was
really a storm in the NLP field so you
can can see this if you go for instance
on paper with code if you check this
curve showing the the state-ofthe-art at
various time which you see is that in
around the end of 2017 beginning of 2018
you see this very strong slope up upward
right there was like performance was
basically pling for like years right
here we see that on on N since basically
2009 we did not really move up anything
and then from like summer 200 18 17 tagm
was already kind of a first transfer
learning approach actually and then with
Transformer we were moving upward very
strongly Squad two you see also the same
very strong increase in the performance
of the model by using bird you see the
jump bird single model there very strong
jump 10
points um in exact match here metric and
then well you can say maybe we're
platting again today I think most of the
the reason we're platting is that squ 2
is now kind of saturated actually as a
benchmark and so we were following that
very closely uh and basically when GPT
the first of the names so this ones went
out we were actually uh at H
participating in a challenge at at newps
well this is an old slide so we still
call it nips but that's that's not newps
right
2018 we were participating in this
conversational AI challenge so the goal
was um when you have a some sort of
headb you had to like uh take into
account a little persona for your robot
and you have to answer in a in a
convincing way to a user so it's a
little bit like a touring test right but
you have a personal you're supposed to
pretend you're you're this person here
and this uh challenge was interesting
because it came with a nice uh data set
made by by the New York New York
Facebook team and um for this first time
GPT was just out and we were like okay
maybe let's try this GPT let's try thise
training approach for for generative
task as well a lot of people were just
using this model for classification task
and so we tried for the first time to
use it for really purely generative task
like Chad and the results you can see on
the right were really impressive we we
were directly on top of the leaderboard
of competition and by a very strong
margin the perplexity the First Column
you were like perplexity is is a kind of
an exponential Matrix so it's quite hard
to divide by two the perplexity but we
were like two times lower than the other
than the other model well this Matrix
well if if you've done a little bit of
generative NLP and you will learn that
in the course here it's very hard to
evaluate so this did not translate
always in human evaluation but it was
still already very very very impressive
and when we studyed a little bit and
compared to the other uh teams what we
saw is that if some were uh very good on
the validation set they often go uh went
very down on the on the hin test set so
if you've been doing a little bit of
kaggle you know that this mostly means
that you're starting to overfit on the
validation public the public data set
and some team were a bit lower and
staying lower right which is more like a
sign of kind of underfitting if you want
and what we saw is that our approach was
both using transfer learning and
Transformer as well but transfer
learning I think is the strongest
ingredient um using transfer learning we
were both very strong validation set and
we stayed very robust on the on the test
set and so this led us uh in the next
summer in June June 2019 to do a very
long tutorial around transfer learning
in NLP with a few a few friends
Sebastian rder Matthew pet who basically
created this this field swaba who also
actually did really great stuff I won't
show here but you should check them out
and what we saw there well what we tried
to do there is try to explain a little
bit what was the IDE and so just as an
Insight you will learn more in the
course but basically this is the like
the separate ingredient of transfer
learning is that uh in in traditional
machine learning we had all these
separate tasks this is on the left you
had task one you wanted to do n you had
the data set for n and you basically
randomly initialize your model on
training from scratch on this data set
if you are now trying to do
summarization of chat B
you will gather another data set of
summarization or chat but and you will
again just create a machine Learning
System specialized for this task and if
you had another task again same thing
you will have very separate pipelines
and very separate uh systems who are
already well at the each time train from
scratch and the approach of transfer
learning was to do a little bit more
like I would say human do which is that
we don't randomly initialize our brain
each time we tackle a new task right
what we do is that we use all the
knowledge that we've learned in the
class in in our life experiences to
bootstrap our learning right and so when
we have a new task we just reuse all
this knowledge that we have and this
give us mostly two main advantages that
we see also when we when we reproduce
that with with machine learning models
which is first that we are very data
efficient because we can feel the gaps
between all the the examples that people
are are giving of of new task and so we
have data efficient and we usually reach
better performances and this is also
related because we can fill the Gap uh
between all the between the data
examples that we have on the on the new
new Target task we can reach better
performances and transfer learning is a
way to try to do the same for for
machine learning so to try to build this
kind of generic knowledge that can be
reused on many many
tasks so we have we have questions that
could go here Tom is is there a
systematic way to estimate how many
annotated samples uh to train to fine
tune an existing model for instance on a
on an a
task yeah that's a good question um it's
quite different it's quite dependent uh
so really the the direction the field is
trying to go is toward few what we call
few shut so using less and less example
so I mean requiring less and less
examples so for some task that you will
see in the course you can actually do
zero shot like Tech classification you
actually in many case don't need any
example but then it's it's always very
dependent on how specific your domain is
and and typically the more specific your
domain is the more you will need example
and in some case you might be you might
still be outside of the pre-training
domain of the model where you and then
you will need quite a large data set
yeah
thanks and so um yeah let's go yeah why
would this work in NLP why you probably
have the intuition but here they are the
idea is that many NLP task if you look
them from if you like take a step back
they share a common knowledge about
language they share that uh oops full
screen yeah basically if you if you know
for instance um adjectives if you know
Linguistics uh then it will help you a
lot for instance if you want to do ner
right you want to identify I don't know
the name of organization if your model
already if your model already have a
good knowledge about Linguistics and
know what is a noun that will help it a
lot because it will know that name of
organization are very likely nouns okay
they are not adjectives they are not
verbs so only thing can be useful for
the model the same right if your task is
in English if your model know a little
bit about English it can just learn
basically the missing pieces that it has
on your task and don't and won't spend
like won't need I would say like half of
your um training data set just to learn
how English Works in general right so
task can also inform each other
typically as I as I told you syntax and
semantics they are often related if
something is a noun that's also mean
that is has it has a meaning related to
to a noun if it's an adjective that's
here to kind of change the meaning of a
noun so only thing um obviously
annotated data data you know that is
rare it's very difficult so the more we
can gather it the more we can gather
several data sets together to build a
bigger one the better it is for our
model we know that these new network
models they are still data hungry right
we don't we don't have a lot of feature
that's the nice thing about them but the
cont the the counterpart is that they
are that angry because they will need to
learn this feature themselves and now
the most I would say a down on Earth
reason why it works is that when we try
it works so that's currently the state
of thee art for many many NLP task it's
to use this transfer learning so that's
also a good reason to think that well
maybe it has reason to work so I talk a
lot about science here like transfer
learning Revolution is is a scientific
revolution in the field but uh if you're
here today it's also because you you
probably following our open our open
source work and this was kind of started
in parallel to that we always thought
that open source and open science were
going hand in hand and so very early we
started to open source some models so
the first one we did is here it's now uh
the summer of 2018 so just before
basically this this transfer learning re
Revolution really really began and so we
we did this new cerence which was a
cerence model for
Spacey uh which already so very show
very interesting performances for for
also a pre-train actually NE network but
only for reference and then there was
obviously this GPT so I told you we were
using the first version of GPT in this
first competition and that's where
basically we understood that wow this
was very powerful and before before
using it as always we actually release
an open source version so actually a bit
later we discovered that some other
competitor also used our open source GPT
in the same competition so it was very
very interesting we actually made a
paper together at at ACL a year later so
it's a b open source way of hugging face
always trying to do something
collaboratively with everyone I think
that we we can just get this the sum of
every open source thing is is larger
than the having just everything private
models and this two these two early
effort and the interest we saw from
people led us to try to do that uh again
and this led us to first um the first uh
Stone of Transformers which was this
conversion of birth in py so in October
there was this birth model from Google
and people like wow this this is really
an impressive model and so when the the
code was open source in t of Flor one at
the time we thought oh that's a little
bit a shame because uh T of Flor one is
still a little bit difficult to use
right and there was pyos already at that
time it was pyto version 0.3 but it was
still quite interesting and easy to use
and so we decided okay let's convert
this T of model in Pion let's see if
people will be uh we will be able to use
it easier right and our idea here was
basically that well first at that time
Birds sounded like a very large model it
was 300 million parameters which today
sounds like maybe the smallest model
that you that you use at least in the
research field but at that time it was
like really really large and so we like
nobody will be able to train that so we
should make it easy to use the pre-train
weights that that Google really nicely
released and to make it the easiest we
should actually have them also in
PTO and so that's what we did um and
that's that lead to this first uh
version called a pyos pre-trained
bird and this was really very far from
Transformers uh but we had a few initial
IDE that evolved so One initial idea was
that we could also host the pretrain
weights on our S3 buckets so that people
didn't have to to to go through the the
painful process of download and
converting them and we could maybe just
load them and here we were inspired by
by Joel Gus's nicely
um nicely made from pre-t tray method in
alen NLP which which I found very very
nice with just one one line of python
you could download a pre-train model in
Ln NLP and so I was like okay let's
actually use the same
ID and so this was the first thing uh
and this evolve over the coming two
years I would say from 2018 to 2020 to a
fully fledged Git Version model Hub that
you will see today which both I think
give you very uh wide access to the
model it's very easy to ins to inspect
it and at the same time give you a lot
of uh interesting like widget to play
with the model online API to use it very
easily so all this you will see in the
class but that's very interesting and
the first idea was also just to give
access to birds right but then I was
like okay we've actually have an was SC
for GPT another for bir why not actually
make them in a single library and this
led us very quickly to basically a
single API which today I think W not far
from a 100 different
architectures which is the the today
Transformers and so this the first
version was pyto Transformers with with
four
architectures and quickly we thought now
t oflow one is a little bit hard to use
but t oflow two is quite nicely done
actually and so you're like maybe maybe
we could have both pyto and tensor FL
two in the same framework maybe we could
even make it this so if you want to use
TPU to train your model on TPU because
you have like free free access you
should and then if we want to find you
the same model in pyto you should be
able to switch very easily from one to
the other and so we Tred to make this
these three main the these two main
framework at that time and then then
later Jacks and flag which are more more
recent in the same framework and we saw
that was actually not not so difficult
to get them all
together and to get what is now
Transformers right not not anymore P
Transformer while p is still I think
maybe the better supported one but
tensor FL and Jacks are very very
strongly
improving um and so this was a
Transformer and what we witness is this
basically explosion in the number of
architecture on model most of them are
today in Transformers because it's very
easy to add new one and so you can see
from bird there were a lot of following
work trying to experiment with variance
in the architecture I think maybe exet
is a good example where they try to do
both some autoaggressive but also
bidirectional way to do um to to do a
forward past in the neural
network and one question became um what
is important from all for all this model
I mean how do they compare right how do
you select the model which one do you
know you want to use and here I think
what's what became also quite clear in
in the sub in the subsequence here was
that actually more than architecture it
was actually the data that matter a lot
so I talk about Excel net which was very
interesting as a different architecture
and actually got a lot better
performances than bird at the time and
people are like wow we should experiment
with various architectures for modifying
the Transformers and this subsequent
work from Facebook called Roberta
actually show that um
it's not so much the architecture but
just the data excelnet was actually
trained on a lot more data than ber and
that's actually what matter more than
the architecture and so robera took very
basic Transformers just exactly the same
as B and then just train it on more data
and they got state-of-the-art results
and this was then show in the these two
other graph which are from the neural
scaling paper and they show that
basically the the architecture was the
the performance were really weakly
sensitive to the AR Ure so you see at
the top you see this very flat curve for
Feit for forward ratio this very flat
curve for aspect ratio and these are all
logarithmic curve so they actually spend
very large um aspect ratio and basically
as long as you stay not so far from the
middle you're pretty good the
architecture just don't really matter
that much and the T5 paper who came who
came out later also confirm this
basically the the early Transformer
paper were already very close to the
optimal Arch Ure but what's very
important is this data set this uh graph
on the lower left where you see the data
set size this is also from from the
neural scaling paper from from open Ai
and you see that just by increasing the
data set size you have this very
predictable increase in performances so
here this is the test loss so lower is
better and this actually brought us to
this question well actually modern
architecture what is important here is
data and so the a year later
2020 actually or maybe
2019 uh we decided to do a new library
around data we are like okay we we also
need to focus on data now and so this
new library was called data sets where
early name was NLP but the for for a
long time now the name is thata set and
this Library also got some quite strong
interests uh from the community it
passed 10K Stars well I don't know how G
how GitHub stars are are relevant as a
measure of of interest but it's also
widely used by by a lot of follow works
so I think it's very nice and this
Library the idea was dat access to data
is also very difficult today in NLP
mostly because the situation is very
fragmented if you want to use a data set
you typically need to find where is the
code somewhere on GitHub you need also
to pre-process it and you actually spend
a lot of time doing the same work to
pre-process the data set a lot of people
are just writing their CSV or G loader
so maybe we could share this work and
avoid this and just jump to the data
structure that was one note another one
was that uh also with this very large
language model we're using now terabytes
of data and this this can be very
difficult to handle on your at least on
your personal laptop right if you want
to train a model on one terabyte of data
like Roba this is really a pain because
you typically can't load that in Ram you
need to find a smart way to do like just
loading the the current batch or
prefetching and so we thought maybe we
should solve all these issues at the
same time and the idea was that data set
could be a way to kind of centralize
access to to NLP data set at the
beginning now it's expanded to speech
and images but at the beginning it was
really about NLP data set and also to
cover more languages right uh NLP
English I mean is
really the dominant language in research
but in production today it's not
dominant language right we have a lot of
other well I mean still the dominant
language but we have a lot of other
languages that are that are very
important and and every time you're
you're actually an NLP um person working
in
another country than the us or UK
basically you want to or India you want
to work with other languages and so this
led us to developing data set around
this efforts so at the end of November
uh well one year ago now November 2020
we did a First Community event where we
said to the community
uh well with 15 people at H face trying
to add data set if you want you can join
this is going to be fun we're going to
do uh this together you will be on our
slack we'll talk a little bit um and
also we'll do some swag and everything
and this was usely po hugely um popular
actually we had I think about 300 people
joining to help us we were definitely a
little bit overwhelmed by the success of
this Fair Community effort um but it was
very nice also in terms of adding data
set in many many languages and the idea
is that all these data set were then
then very easy to access and this could
Foster more research on multilinguality
and thing and so um this led us also to
write a paper with um with the whole
team and also there are there are also
some community members actually in this
paper uh you see
Gan bit they are both like Community
contributor and to submit it today this
year to mnlp where I just actually want
the best demonstration paper so I think
this is very typical hugging facee thing
where we do something very open source
uh we do that with the community at
least we we invite everyone to join if
they want to participate and then we
also do that as a science effort and
this all just go together to make
something very impactful and so there is
today also this Hub that you will see in
the in in the course where where you
today we have about well not so far from
2,000 data set openly accessible you can
even Explore them on the
Hub and so this was the 2020 effort
around data data and what happened in
2021 um that was open science more and
big science well what happened I would
say it's very personal work through so I
would mean what I actually spend a lot
of my time on was this big scientif
fault and here the idea was that um
maybe it's time to do very large
collaboration in research in NLP and the
example well I'm I'm a physics PhD
formerly and so I in physics when we
have like very expensive things uh we
actually um gather as as a lot of like
research lab and try to build them
together one good example is the large
hydon collider which is in Europe which
is very very large particle physics
research tool it cost I think 10 billion
to build and it has involve really a
huge research community and has led to a
lot of research work like you have about
3,000 papers uh this led to the
discovery of many hard run thing like
that and so the idea was maybe it's time
to do that in Ai and NLP and so maybe
why I mean why why would it be TI to do
to do something like that well again I
think um because uh there was some if if
you follow what I've been saying up to
now right there there is this idea that
larger and larger data sets are are
something interesting some some
direction we want to go um this was
proved again by by the gpt3 paper that
that show that if you scale again the
number of tokens here you see it in
green on the Corpus side and this is
again a logic scale so the the scaling
is really like how much is
it six order of f no two order two order
of magnitude bigger than gpt2 well if
you scale both the Corpus size and the
parameter size you see like very
interesting new effects and this effects
are few shots so um recently I mean just
the beginning of the talk some somebody
asked how many how many example would
you need and here in this few shot
example you can see that we want we just
need like 10 examples to get very strong
performances so I don't remember exactly
uh what this curve was in terms of
accuracy maybe I think it was a
classification task but this one this
one is just extracted from the gpt3
paper so you can find it back and they
have a lot of cores similar to this they
have a lot of Curves similar to this and
so there was this idea if you scale this
a lot you get some interesting new
effects and then quickly what you saw is
that uh there were new there were a lot
of announcement of reproduction na Labs
train gpt3 like model for Korean
entropic a startup of the barrier raised
a lot of money to train similar model AI
21 also trained a massive model called I
think
Jurassic and another company called
coair also raised a lot of money to
train all this model and elter was also
this this grassroot Collective who
trying to reprodu so so a lot of people
were trying for reproducing this but uh
for diversity of reason we were not
super convinced about this mostly
because like all these private company
did not seems to be uh targeting like
open source release and uh and UT was
was the only one but there was still
some main problems so here is a few
issues I see first all these model they
are not designed as research tool
they're really designed by company to be
like private thing that they want to use
for their private product but they are
not designed as research thing so it's
very typically it's very difficult for
academic researcher to be involved in in
the development of these models right
and typically what you when you look at
the teams who build them they're like
yeah they're like small smaller than
they should be in my opinion mostly
because they just belong to one one
company and mostly there is as again a
lot of environmental cost to training
all this model in parallel if they were
open source we wouldn't need to retrain
them like in in 60 company we could just
share one and that would be a nice model
for doing all our experiments
um and there was some ethical and and
social issues mostly since the very um
beginning of GPT there there there's
been a stream of paper investigating
okay how are these very large test opra
and we saw that they were lacking some
something for instance they were lacking
representativeness of of some population
um there also some typically have some
stereotypes so basically it's very hard
to investigate these train data set also
because they are typically not open
sourced and and so this called in my
opinion for like a most a more open uh
and collaborative way to develop this
and this is actually possible because if
you look in the public uh you see that
there are super computer that are very
powerful that actually almost fully
accessible I mean you just need to
submit um like a grun an application to
say I need some compute times on this
and they have like almost uh 2,700 V100
GPU so that's quite a lot of comput
power you can train a very large
language model di so early this year I
start to talk with the operator on
builder of uh of Jean which is one super
computer located in France that we knew
a little bit from earlier and they say
yeah I mean come come train your model
basically on a super computer we're very
happy so we we kind of discuss a little
bit internally and then we we decided
that we should actually invite everyone
to come join and to train this model
with us and in particular invite the
academic community which was typically
outside of all these uh model creations
and so we file a grun application for
enough compute time to train a very
large language model and this was the
beginning of big
science and big science has been going
on for like six months a little bit more
now nine months and it has already uh
produced very interesting papers so if
you've been following uh hugging face
account you probably saw the the tzo
paper which involved actually uh 40
authors um so some of them are from
Huggy phase but a lot of them are not
from Huggy phase some are from yeah many
University um and so this type of um
papers I think is very interesting
because it's outside of the box so it's
fully open it's fully collaborative and
it's also show that you can outperform
typically gpt3 on the Zero shot
Benchmark with a model which is 16 times
smaller so now what we are trying to do
is to actually increase the size to 16
times larger so that's what that's what
will begin roughly next January
and to train this very large model on
Jon to see if we how far we can go right
with the same idea of like openness open
sharing collaborative effort and so
what's next for 2022 at hugging phase
well there is obviously education if we
want to have a beneficial impact we
think that this is the the way to start
when we talk about bias in data set when
we thought about understanding your
model knowing what is important for your
model basically we think that we should
share all the knowledge we
have there is this strong Community
you're all here today I'm very happy
about that to because you basically you
following more or less what we've been
doing open source this is our DNA and
open science they go hand in hand for me
sharing knowledge we try to keep finding
for beneficial responsible AI I talk a
little bit about data set this is very
important I think to understand the bias
to understand the bias of your model as
well and basically try to make this yeah
an in inclusive place right and while
doing all that doing also this exciting
research when I say we scale this this
new model to to very large uh sizes we
also try to have some fun and not taking
us too seriously uh which I think is
also
um uh specificity of hugging face and
why maybe we have this hugging face
emoji I would say as as the name of
company so welcome to this course I'm
very happy very excited about this uh
this second chapter I think it's it's
very interesting you will learn a lot
and thank you for being here
today thanks a lot Tom um we have a few
questions I've IED for the end because
they are very general and not directly
related to what you are talking about uh
one is uh you talked about a lot about
Transformers but what about using graph
networks in the tasks graph structures
could capture data with complex
structures and relationships and GN
provides opportunity to study on model
complex data representation for NLP
tasks yeah that's a good question I mean
in all generality you could consider
Transformer as as a sort of graph NE
Network it's not Spar though it's fully
connected so maybe it could be more
efficient but if you look at like a
Transformer with SP attention in my
opinion it's it's really close to it's
really close to some graph new network
in particular if you use if you use
weight sharing like Universal
Transformers um I think in NLP
Transformer are kind of dominant today
uh but yeah as I told you in my opinion
the main aspect of the revolution is
about transfer learning more than the
specific architecture so if tomorrow
there is a more efficient architecture
than Transformer uh then I would be
happy to follow follow the the work
there and basically uh switch to
that yeah I think
yeah uh another question we had was uh
more about theing face ecosystem uh EOS
ising face becoming commercial from open
source there are many parts of the that
are no paid model training for instance
we go to NLP please help me understand
the portion of Open Source versus
paid oh yeah yeah so so it's still um I
mean the idea of f face is I think
somehow very very typical like open core
model so everything is open source but
you need to do the training yourself you
need to do the training Loop yourself so
we do provide examples uh that's
actually Silva has been doing a lot of
work on on the examples to to have like
um an efficient training so you have
open source code to to train this and
then we also provide some paid solution
which are mostly there I would say to
facilitate your work so typically if
you're in a company you don't want to
wait you don't you don't have time to
actually explore everything yourself you
want some some help then we then we also
here to help and then we have some
specific solution around making this
model very fast and these are typically
mostly interesting to to companies more
than
researchers because they try to lower
the latency uh strongly and then here
these are also yeah paid product because
people who are interested in them are
typically companies who can pay for them
so the idea is that if you're new if
you're like new to the to the field if
you're hobbyist if you're a researcher
you can use all of this for free and
then if you have some like specific
needs like you need to go very fast to
put that in production you need to have
like very low latency because you have
huge band within production then we also
here to help but then we we help with
our with our like additional
services that makes sense another
question you ined a little bit about
that at the end but more fun question is
how did the nameing face and the use
come
about yeah this came from our very early
uh Inception as a game company right we
were doing a this kind of talking chat
but it was mainly for for Millennials
for kids or young adults so we wanted a
fun name we Al thought thought it would
be fun if at some point we became a very
big company uh I don't know if we if
we'll do that one day but if we like IPO
and then we have an emoji instead of
like this very serious name that
everybody has we thought yeah let's keep
this Emoji um and I think now it's part
of the fun we we like a lot of people
are takings sometimes a bit too
seriously I think in the world so we're
here to to say yeah this is uh this is
important but having fun is also
important and a last fun question that
people were interested in is more
personal what do you use to build train
models notebooks vs code Vim
other yeah I typically use vs code um
notebook I'm always lost in the order of
the sales but maybe I have a bad bad bad
workflow now I typically use notebook to
explore data I think it's very it's very
nicely done for that that that's the
best way to to explore data and then
when I when I train I typically want
something which is very producible so I
I switch to something where I can get
version cleanly and then more like
typical B code
yeah nice uh thanks a lot for for your
talk it was very very
interesting and I think we're ready for
next speaker leis if you want to in
him oh I think Le is not hearing us
anymore so that's why there was this
side can you hear me yeah
right sorry what did you say I just
dropped off for a sec I just said I
think we ready to introduce our next
speaker if you great so let me add Jay
Alamar to the stream he Jay and B you I
think you might be muted at the moment
yes
hello great so I I think Jay probably
needs no introduction to everyone who's
here to uh listen about Transformers um
I think all of us have kind of started
by trying to read the attention is all
you need paper and gotten completely
confused by this crazy architecture
diagram and then immediately gone to
Jay's super influential uh blog post
called The Illustrated Transformer where
he really nicely shows um kind of
conceptually how these things work and
then there's a whole series of beautiful
blog posts ranging from pandas to numpy
to BT GPT I mean the whole works so
thank you Jay for this amazing service
you've done to the community you've kind
of demystified Transformers um which is
amazing and today um Jay's going to talk
to us about a gentle visual introduction
to Transformer models so I'll add yep
great you got your thing there
and are we okay on audio all good
amazing thank you so much that's a very
kind int production uh happy to be here
uh speaking about
Transformers uh there's a a couple of
examples on a notebook this is a URL to
it but it's a you know just a very
simple sort of sort of notebook um to go
over it
um to to give some um let's say history
um these are some some Milestones from
the history of writing right so uh first
time sort of people put
um drawings on tablets um and then
people put language carved it carved
their laws of an entire let's say
Society on on a column that's hamur
hamurabi law the second image below then
people started using paper um and then
we have something like the the printing
machine or the printing press that sort
of um pushed the next let's say
Revolution and books became cheaper to
get and knowledge and literacy became
uh easier so once you need a book you
don't need to go and copy it with with
your hand um that sort of change the
world and I do have a sense looking back
at the history that NLP via sort of what
machine learning is is enabling us to do
that we could be at at a at a historical
sort of Turning Point where exactly are
we did it happen the last two or three
years or is it going to happen in the
next few years um it's very hard to tell
if you're not sort of looking back back
into history but I'm extremely
fascinated um by these sort of language
models and I'll tell you a little bit
why so yeah just a brief bit about
myself I I have been blogging about
machine learning and uh
Transformers uh machine learning for
maybe five six years a Transformer sort
of since uh I wanted to understand the
paper and this is sort of a map that I
used to for me to understand the paper
and turned out to be useful to to other
people as well the blog has gotten about
four million page views just because the
the topic became super interesting to to
people and then I wrote about other
types of Transformers as well as NLP
technology so embeddings word ofac gpt3
ber and I do some some videos on on
YouTube as well to sort of explain some
of these um I do work at cooh here um as
as sort of Thomas mentioned we work on
large language models we offer sort of
large representational language models
kind of like B and large uh generation
language models kind of like GPT so
these are massive language models via
API for people to experiment with and
and deploy in in Industry so this is the
URL and we're we're hiring at the
moment one thing to allude to uh that
Thomas mentioned is that Transformers
has taken NLP uh by storm uh but not
only NLP but also like computer vision
and it's like going out of out of NLP
this is the the superglue um and you can
see that Transformer and Transformer
based models uh have have dominated the
leaderboards um if you go and search on
Google so I have bring up this example
for people who sort of want to
understand a little bit more of the
current applications so if you go on to
search on on Google um and you type some
some words and you get some
recommendations your your keyboard would
give you some recommendations but also
the search engine would give you some
some recommendations so let's say you
search for Siri technology you get this
page um and then when you click on it
sometimes you get these highlighted sort
of notes I asked people which step in
this process used a language model um
and in an audience like this I think you
would realize that this is maybe a a
trick question and it's in all of them a
language model was used so
um auto complete complete and sort of
next word uh can be used via let's say
language models um this
summarization um and highlighting uh
these are all sort of language model uh
tasks but there's even one that is more
important which is where sort of Google
got you the
results so to give some sort of examples
yes so we some of these tasks are let's
say autocomplete text summarization
question answering semantics search um
and if you use Gmail you have some of
these um suggested responses that's
response selection that's also another
thing that language models are are
heavily used for so we're not talking
about specific just research um or you
know interesting ideas these are heavily
in application right now just even less
than less than a year since like one of
these papers is written it it goes into
into industry um really quickly so this
is sort of across the board Google
translate search uh all the speech
detection um and then using it in in in
search as well so like a year I think
after the birth paper was out um the
Google search team said that it
implementing let's say semantic search
using a model like Bert represented the
biggest Leap Forward in the past five
years and one of the biggest leaps
forward in the history of
search uh gpt3 took the World by storm
so many interesting applications there
uh I think most of of the team here has
has has looked at it so to think about
Transformer language models uh for a
second let's look at U one of the
developments that that uh have changed
the game um that it broke down this
training process into two steps one is
pre-training where a model is trained on
a lot of data um and then you fine-tune
it you train it further for for a
specific uh use case
so if you want to create let's say a new
um semantic
or sentiment analysis let's say
classifier you don't have to train a
model from scratch uh you can train a
model that already understands English
or multilingual or whatever language
that you're so these are one of the this
is one of the uh developments sort of
that that made these these models um
revolutionary um the training process of
a language model and I'm here speaking
about a a what's typically called a
language model which is an auto
regressive language model kind of like
GPT it's trained on a on a very basic
task which is you give it let's say
three tokens or three words and uh you
hold off what the corre correct word is
so a robot must obey but you don't tell
it to obey you just give it the three
tokens or three words it will make a
prediction the model is not trained so
it will output a random
output we know what the actual output
that we are expecting thing is we
calculate the error we update the model
um and then we do this for a lot of uh
tokens 300 billion in in GPT 3's case
and then once you've train pre-trained
it you can deploy it or fine-tune it or
prompt engineer it for for these other
uh use
cases to tackle the the architecture a
little bit um I've always felt that it's
easier to look at it as just one black
box and the initial Transformer uh was
about um translation so you give it a
sentence in in French and it outputs a a
sentence in English so uh you can
visualize it kind of like this and then
if you to look under the hood it has two
major components an encoder and a
decoder and these encoder and decoder
are are made up of of blocks uh six
blocks in the encoder and six in the
decoder that's the initial sort of
Transformer paper um and then these are
the main architecture ideas um I think
that are good to establish first before
thinking about different types of
Transformers so the initial Transformer
was an encoder decoder model so that
works really well for say things like um
machine translation uh but also there
are still models that are you know
continuing to toh tackle this this
structure so it's still very useful uh
on certain uh use cases so T5 t0 that
was sort of recently uh developed as
well is is these encoder decoder um and
I think Mina Google ai's large um chat
botties is one of these encoder decoder
models on the other hand you have models
that are trained completely using
decoders um so these are the your your
GPT models uh that are just like the
traditional autor regressive um models
and then you have birt like uh model
models structured using only the encoder
sort of Stack um and that is tends to be
called masked language modeling so you
have language models mask language
models and you have like encoder decoder
uh Transformers so this is to to orient
yourself and all of these are widely in
use uh a lot of them are have specific
tasks that they do better in than the
others uh our talk will focus um on the
Transformer uh language model uh so this
is going to be
um the type of model that we focus
on um another idea uh is how many layers
can you sort of Stack how many blocks
can you can you stack in Bert large has
about 24 gpt2 large has about 36 so
these are another aspect let's say of
Transformers is uh so you can talk about
how large the the neural networks inside
are but also how many blocks that you
stack to get your
model so let's talk about language
models um I found that there's
a two really good examples to to break
down the components of a a Transformer
uh layer so let's think about a model
that has let's say only one one
layer if you give the model an example
of this input which is the
Shashank and then this model is trained
so it has hopefully seen uh words kind
of like this or phrases kind of like
this before um you would be able to
think that it it is able to guess what
the next word is and this is a a
reference to uh the film The Shashank
Redemption um and I I tried this using
the distilled gbt2 example and when you
pass it Des Shashank it gives you this
completion so it's able to actually know
what word I was expecting um after
Shashank and this really explains to you
one of the two major components of a
transformer block which is the feed
forward neural network so in the
training when the model was trained on
vast amount of of data uh previously it
it is able to calculate these
probabilities of words appearing after
the current context that you have so two
words here what would the third be and
this is a a very similar so this is not
new as a technology in Transformers this
is very similar to previous uh language
models and then three Gs and NRS uh that
were calculated using just counting how
many times uh this word has appeared
before sort of or after this context and
creating a probability uh distribution
or score via that so this is one of the
two major components the feed forward
neural network and this is an example
where it shines it was able to sort of
um remember or have a calculation of
what the next word would be just judging
on what the model has seen
before um this is a a paper from 2003
about these models and how the they were
there sort of previously and
Transformers build on on top of
this now the second component is a
little bit more complex and this is a
great example to uh Illustrated So when
you say the chicken did not cross the
road because it and you want the model
to complete what the next word would be
now the model cannot only calculate you
know what words usually appear after the
word it um that would not produce a
really good model it would not be able
to fit its data set really well and
before it sort of does that um it needs
to resolve what does it refer to here
does it refer to the chicken or does it
referred to the road so that ambiguity
is is a is is there and we can throw
this as at a small GPT uh example and we
can see if we say the the chicken didn't
cross the road because it was
covered in grass so that's probably the
road right um he thought the sun wasn't
so bad then then now I don't know maybe
it was maybe the chicken was covered in
grass and that the sun was not so bad so
this is sort of a good example of this
other component of a transformer block
which is self attention what self
attention does is that when the model is
processing this token self attention
Associates it either with the chicken or
with the road or with mixture of both
and really that it's a mixture of of the
entire sentence um so that is one of the
major things that Transformers brought
uh I guess to NLT in addition to um
being easier and better to run in
parallel uh as compared to rnns which
were um used heavily before sort of
Transformers took over so these are the
two components self attention which you
know whenever you're processing a token
it B makes the in its understanding or
representation of that token uh relevant
information from other um parts of of
the input um and then feed forward which
is neural network which is um Builds on
top of
that the idea of tokenization is another
uh important one uh so the example that
I showed you here was a little bit
simplified when I actually throw the Sha
shank at the tokenizer of gpt2 is what
I'm using here it would break it down
kind of like this so these two words
would be for
tokens and then a through the tokenizer
that would be translated into token IDs
um and these token IDs will be the ones
that are uh hitting the the model and
then the model outputs something that we
can translate into a a word using the
token again and so if you're to to work
with with Bert or GPT models these are
the two let's say components pieces of
code and that that you'll have to deal
with the tokenizer which translates
between our words and let's say token
IDs and the actual model which has never
seen any words has only seen token
IDs so I I'll leave you to be able to um
go through the
uh notebook
um and this is sort of a an interesting
uh idea that I thought uh so gpt3 this
was one of the let's say outputs of of
gpt3 saying to be clear I'm not a person
I'm not self-aware I'm not conscious I
can't feel pain uh I don't enjoy
anything I am cold calculating machine
designed to simulate a human
response so this and other sort of
interesting Generations from from
massive language models are very
interesting if you can think of them as
um you know these were outputed by a
machine now definitely should be
suspicious until you see sort of what
the prompt was uh but it's still
interesting uh but what's more
interesting is that the model has never
actually seen language it has only seen
word like token IDs kind of like this so
when the model says this actually this
is what its output is it has never
touched or seen uh words but it just is
able to model sequences let's say of of
numbers and then um
embeddings embeddings is is the next uh
idea here which is
breathing uh meaning into numbers into
these token IDs
um and so when you download let's say
the GPT model you would get with it a
table of uh let's say vocabulary size
and and embedding for each word that the
model knows or each token that in the
model's
vocabulary uh this is how you can look
at it I don't know if this is up to dat
with the latest uh versions but uh it
was when I was sort of looking at it so
and you can just pass it let's say the
token ID so this is the token ID of the
word the and you can if you're like me
and just you're curious and you want to
look at these numbers do they make sense
they look like
this so we have our words uh they're
converted into tokens through embedding
they're converted into vectors kind of
like the numbers that that that we saw
previously and these are really the
input into the Transformer block uh and
if the input is let's say four tokens
You' have these four tracks going
through the Transformer block and an
output at each
one and then however many blocks that
you have you can sort of uh each block
works on the output of the of the
previous one and these are called dat
States when when you're doing uh text
generation uh the one that you you
predict the next token using this final
one so if we're predicting let's say the
word Redemption it would the model would
be working off of this final hidden
state of the final
token okay so how do we turn computation
into into language how do we project the
output into into language and it looks
kind of like this so where this is the
last hidden State um of the last token
so the model has processed it done a lot
of crunching and then it outputs this
this one vector uh the let's say
language model has would would project
that so it would give a score to each
word in its vocabulary each token in its
vocabulary and we just pick the highest
one or we can that's one type of of
output selection there are other
decoding strategies is is is the word
for this but say you just pick the
highest one that would be the word
Redemption
um so now you scale it and that's how
you sort of have these massive um
language models they proc process all of
the all of these tokens and then in the
end they give you an output and you feed
that autor regressively so this token
that comes out is fed back into the
model and that's how the model continues
to produce token after
token hey Jay I have a question um about
scaling so what do you mean by this is
this uh scaling like the architecture or
do are there other things we should
consider when we talk about scaling
Transformers yes exactly so I'm talking
about how do go from let's say gpt2 to
gpt3 uh so you have larger models larger
uh training sets um and then like even
you you tra you layer a higher let's say
number of of layers or more more
Transformer
blocks great and then a kind of
follow-up question would be um so at coh
here I think you mentioned you you you
guys are also training large language
models yourself yes and so I'm kind of
wondering like what kind of
considerations go into curating the data
set
um when you're when you're doing this
because we know that gpt3 for example
has a wide set of kind of know and
biases and can lead to some kind of
generations that maybe are sort of
harmful or offensive and so on I'm just
kind of curious how how you guys think
about this um yes yes absolutely so
there's the the team works on filtering
the the data sets for for for toxicity I
think there's a there's a paper also uh
there that I can I can share after with
the team so uh exactly that that
filtering off off the data set is is a
very important component that leads to
models hopefully that that can produce
better
Generations awesome thank you amazing
thank you so
much ah so was that the end of your talk
that is the end of my talk great cool
cool great so we have a few more
questions um on the forums so this one
is is more of a um say general question
put it here in the chat so do you see a
future in symbolic learning rather than
probabilistic approaches and I think
this is kind of like you know the the
big topic on Twitter between Barry
Marcus and um you know other people who
are like connectionists and I'm curious
to see what your thoughts are true yeah
I don't have sort of much of a an
opinion I think we can probably use a
little bit of both the probabilistic has
really proven itself so I don't think
you can go without the probabilistic but
can you infuse it with uh a little bit
more rules like that's what we see in
chatbots so to speak you can use some of
the probabilistic but you you have to
sort of encode some some of the some of
your rules uh to to actually have
something that you can let's say ship
out to your customers
now yeah I think a kind of very related
question here is whether like
Transformers or you know deep neuron
networks in general can do true
extrapolation um and you know whether
we're just doing interpolation on some
sort of you know manifold in a lower
Dimension and I I think this is
generally what the symbolists are always
you know wanting us to you know pay
attention to true true and there's
there's some work on on causal sort of
inference uh that's been sort of
Dripping more and more into into NLP and
that sort of maybe goes beyond uh just
let's say correlation into maybe
encoding some some of the of the
causation cool so another question we
have here is um so you know your blog as
I mentioned at the start has kind of
helped everyone visually understand
what's going on under the hood and sort
of what concept or architecture is like
next on your on your list yeah so a lot
of what I focus on especially sort of in
my my work with Co here is how do we get
the best results from these models in
the real world and how do we apply them
to to real world problems so um I've
been thinking about things like you know
what are the best ways to explain and
think about things like prompt
engineering um and you know what's the
best way to sort of you know fine-tune
um the a model what should the data set
sort of uh look like so a lot of it I've
been sort of thinking about the applied
side for a while now and that sort of
gives me some exposure into things like
um or areas that are interesting both on
generation but also on the embedding
side kind of like dense retrieval and
semantic search um and these sort of you
know very interesting uh applications of
of models both of the bir uh and the GPT
types awesome I think we have another
question here it's a bit of a long one
I'll see if I can just read it out it
doesn't quite fit so um it says let's
see so for T5 um there's been around
three approaches that have been used to
fine-tuned pre-trained models for all
Downstream tasks so this is kind of like
where you fine-tune all of the layers or
you just freeze some layers or you know
do gradual unfreezing and the question
is that for models like Bert um which
are more these encoder based models
models um which of these approaches do
you think is best you know kind of using
freezing or just just fine-tuning the
whole thing yeah so it's a trade-off
it's really a trade-off so you can you
can get some value without fine tuning
you can fit some classifiers on top of
the Frozen model to begin with you can
freeze some layers and uh train let's
say the final layers and you can fine
tune the entire thing um but the more
like fine tuning that you do the more
training that you do that will take more
time it will need a little bit more data
uh there isn't one size fits all
unfortunately in machine learning most
of the answers are always you know
depends on the
case exactly and and I think this is
kind of very closely related to this
follow-up question which is sort of how
how do we know how much we should
fine-tune a pre-trained model so are
there some like General like heris STS
or strategies that you sort of think
about when you're doing fine tuning so
fine tuning is a different is a
different Beast so it's a word that can
use different things the it depends on
the complexity of the task that you want
the model to accomplish so um if the
model has been has come across your task
uh in uh its training set for example
then you don't need a lot of f tuning
because if you let's say get data from
the web and you train the model to do
language modeling on it it would see
things like paragraph and then in
summary and then a sum summary under it
so it wouldn't need a lot of data to
grasp the the concept of of let's say
summarization because it was already
sort of kind of trained on it but if you
have something where uh the the
relationship between the input that you
want and the output is is is difficult
uh then you will need a bit more sort of
data and it's it's similar to however
you want to fit uh features and labels
in a general machine learning uh
algorithm if the relationship is easy if
it's sort of the model is able to do it
with less data if it's complex um then
that's you know you might need infinite
data for it exactly and I I think this
is also perhaps why everyone has got so
excited about models like gpt3 because
they kind of showed like in Tom's talk
you mentioned this kind of curve where
you can see you know the performance as
a function of number of examples and in
the fuse shot case where you only need
10 examples and you still you know
almost you know several tens of points
better than than everything else this is
quite impressive and maybe just one last
question for you because here I guess
you're doing F shot learning is do do
you see this technique of like prompt
engineering or F shot learning becoming
kind of as common place in Industry um
as you know the current Paradigm we use
of you know collecting several thousand
examples and you know training our
classifies them yeah so it is and it
depends on on the use case and it's it's
really better for some use cases uh
rather than than others uh you can have
a lot of let's say cases where you don't
have that data or it's very difficult
but that relationship is somehow encoded
through examples that the model has has
seen before so it's U for people without
a lot of data sets uh fot learning is
one thing to to to to experiment with it
is convenient uh but it has that it's
again it's EMP empirical and
experimental uh sort of in nature uh but
if you have only five or 10 uh or 50
examples uh it's it's worth
experimenting with it if if it's too
expensive for you to actually get enough
of a data set to train a full model
totally so that's I think all the
questions we have from the community
right now and uh thank you once again
for this beautiful talk and for taking
part in this event I think everyone
really enjoys um seeing your your
amazing slides and images amazing thank
you so much I appreciate it love all all
your work happy to be here thank you so
much
right have a good
one uh so so we have a little bit of
time before next speaker time to talk
because Jay was super inside fold and
very clear um so uh I'm going to give
you a quick overview of our part two of
the course uh while we wait for our next
speaker to be fully ready uh let me just
share my
screen and we'll get
going
so part one of the course I was teaching
you the the basics of how to use a
Transformer model uh especially
pre-train model and find unit on a text
classification task uh before sharing it
with the community using our tools uh to
to put it on the model Hub and part two
of the course main goal is to show you
how to tackle any NLP task
so for this we started by bit longer
dive into the data set library and the
tokenizer library because are very
helpful uh to they have lots of useful
tools to tackle some of the most
challenging tasks like for instance
questioning uh so the data set so
chapter five goes over the data set
library and shows you how to to load the
data set especially if it isn't from the
but you have your own data which is
going to be super useful if you want to
tackle your own problem and then uh it's
showing a little bit how to pre-process
that data uh so to select few random
samples how to pre process it uh any how
to split one data set into a training
and validation
Set uh is showing exactly how data sets
work behind the scenes to to make sure
that you don't go out of run if you have
a huge data set using aach Arrow behind
the scenes to to make sure that your
data set is on Diss and not really in
your in your RAM and then it explains it
will explain to you to create your own
data set and upload it to Z and there is
a last section about how to use um how
to do semantic search and using eddings
with f f AIS SS I'm not sure if I'm
supposed to spell it or to say it leis
yeah I never know and I also should
apologize in advance for my Australian
accent so if people are watching all
these videos going what the hell is he
saying
then the subtitles you can activate the
subtitles on each video and they're
pretty good
so um the next chapter is a a deeper
dive into the tokenizers library to
inspect uh what those tokenizers are
backed by the tokenizers library has
tokenizers that are backed by rust but
we call fast tokenizers in the
Transformers Library by opposition to
the to the python tokenizer which we
qualify as slow that's because with the
r Library backing those fast ionizers we
can can parallelize the tokenization and
go like between 10 and 25 times faster
to tokenize gloves of text so this
section will explain to you to train a
new tokenizer for instance if you you
have the GPT model in English but you
want to train a GPT model in your own
language so you'll need to train a new
tokenizer for that but you want to use
the same algorithm as for GPT so there
is one single method to learn and this
chapter tells you all about it that
helps you train your neizer like GPT or
like or like
T5 uh then you have a section about the
fast eizer special powers the first
thing is to evaluate why they are faster
and how much faster they are compared to
slers and then it goes in depth into the
the features that we added in the
tokenizers library that are very helpful
to go back from a token to to the span
of text that generated it which is super
useful for Tan classification or
question answering and so that's why uh
it's then you we do then a deep dive
into the inside the tokon classification
Pipeline and inside the question
answering pipeline to explain exactly
what happens uh between the model
predictions and the answer that the
those pipeline give you and then we we
make a deep dive into what happens
inside the tokenizer so the first step
on the normalization which is like
cleaning the text for instance removing
the accents for for B models or or
lowercasing everything if you have a
model that is used to that and then
there is protonization which is
splitting a text into words uh before
the model of the tokenizer uh is applied
uh for instance here to separates today
into two separate tokens and then post
processor applies the the special toket
for for instance for bir for the Cs at
the beginning and the SE at the end so
the first this the F section goes of a
normalization protonization and then you
have three different algorithm that are
supported by tokenizers Library which
are bpe word piece and unigram and they
both all got they all get their own
section uh to explain to you if they
worked with tokenize input or they were
trained and uh yeah and how you could do
go to to train your own tokenizer using
one of those algorithm and then the last
section in this chapter explain to you
how to build the tokenizer block by
block using the tokenizer library and
then how to use it in the Transformers
library to to tokenize all your text
before training or functioning a model
with your new
tokenizer and chapter seven is really a
big chapter of this part two so as I
said the goal was to teach you how to
tackle any NLP task and this is the
chapter that delivers that so it begins
with token classification which is a bit
like text classification but you have to
predict one label for each token inside
your text then uh we go over Mass
language modeling we F tuning uh birth
model over the MDB data set and we can
see how a model that was used that was
very generic so this is a great mask it
would predict some generic terms and
then after being ftuned on the MDB data
set it will predict movie or film to to
feel the sentence because it's been used
to a data set full of movie
terms the next task is translation how
to translate the text into another
language then there is a world section
about summarization which is taking a
very long text and extracting uh a very
small summary so like very very short
summary for that section to train the
model fast uh we we decided to to to
train an extreme summarizer of movie
reviews uh then there is a section about
caal language modeling which is also
going to show you how to train a new
model from
scratch and lastly a section about
question answering and how to preprocess
and post process the data to create a
model that is capable of finding answer
to questions inside a context like this
one uh which which reible to answer this
question from the from the Transformers
Ry and find the Deep learning library is
backing the Transformers
library and then in chapter eight uh we
did a little bit uh about how to tackle
the most common NLP tasks uh sorry how
to ask for helps when you get a problem
uh so it begins with what to do when you
get an error and in this chapter we
teach you how to read the python thrb
back uh which can be very overwhelming
at first if you don't know what to look
for but hopefully this will help you
analyze your error and help you debug
your own training then we wrote a small
section about how to ask for helps on
the forums uh which is to make sure that
you include all the necessary
information uh so that all members of
the community can help you very fast to
solve to Sol solve your
problem uh We've then made the section
that is more specific about debugging a
machine learning training uh whether if
you're using the trainer API in py or
caras with tensorflow all of those
section both have contact with py or
tflow and you can switch from one to the
other with this little button at the
right
top and so it's going to explain to you
what to look for so the steps uh to look
for first de begining your data then
your model then
perhaps a backward path of the optimizer
step and then we finished this section
with how to write a good issue on GitHub
to make sure again that you include all
the necessary information so that the
maintainers can help you solve your
problem as soon as
possible uh or thebug and make a fix if
necessary in the corresponding
libraries so that's it for for a quick
overview of that part two of the course
we hope you really like it if you have
questions uh about any of those uh Parts
you can go on the forums for a course
section which we showed you before and
in this course section there is one
topic for each of the chapter that we
just created today so don't hesitate to
go there to ask any questions but you
have about the course
content and I think we're ready for next
speaker Lis what do you think yeah maybe
we could just uh for people who are just
joining the stream now just quickly show
um how they can ask questions for the
next speaker oh yes very good idea so
our next speaker is going to be Margaret
Mitchell I'm going to introduce her in a
moment but you should go on this topic
in the course uh category to ask any
questions uh that you want and uh if you
find a question that you would really
like to be asked let's go for instance
in this topic you can see that there is
a little hurt beneath each topic so make
sure that you like the question that you
want to be really asked because if we
have too many questions and don't have
time to ask of them will select the one
that that the most
likes and let me stop sharing my
screen and so like I said our next
speaker is going to be Margaret Michelle
hi
Margaret Hi how are you um I'm very good
so Margaret is a researcher working on
nii currently focus on the in and out of
ethic in artificial intelligent
development in Tech she has published
over 50 papers on natural language
generation assistive technology computer
vision and higher AI ethics and holds
multiple patents in the areas of
conservation generation and sentiment
classification and today she will talk
to us about the values in machine
learning
development so let me put your screen in
the Stream and then we'll let you go on
with your talk it's good everyone can
hear me okay oh it even say so in this
little preview cool um and then to see
the comments I can look maybe on the
right side of the screen um I would be
really happy for people to ask questions
as I go um that said I might get lost in
what I'm doing and miss that someone is
asking a question uh so I'll try my
best okay so hello uh thank you for
having me um I recently joined hugging
face to work on things like values in ml
development um so going to be here I
guess a little bit as a wet blanket but
also hopefully providing uh some useful
insights um into the
development
okay um so by now the machine learning
development pipeline is relatively
familiar to people who work in AI so
first you collect data then you train
and test a model you can add additional
post processing such as selecting among
A ranked list or apply thresholds than
evaluating in order for the model to
Output an eventual decision or answer
and people see the
output but before we even begin the
process the data itself encodes a subset
of human perspectives so what people
choose to talk about and how they talk
about it based on their experience so
the idea that a data set can be unbiased
which is one of these uh sort of
questions that comes up in the data
versus model debates uh it's actually
both can be biased um and saying that a
data set can somehow be unbiased
misunderstands what a data set is by
definition right so a data set is not
everything and all experience for all of
humanity uh in the world ever or in the
universe ever right by definition it is
a slice of all of that it's a subset
it's a snapshot so that means that it is
biased with respect to everything else
in the universe ever right it's a very
limited subset specifically collected
from the world with all kinds of SKS
reflecting the way that people represent
themselves um as well as skews in data
collection and annotation um and the way
that people talk about the world um so
we see biases um we see biases like
reporting bias which is selectively
sharing only specific kinds of
information um think about how often
people announce that they're breathing
for example right uh all these things
are happening all the time we don't
describe them we don't talk about them
they sort of go without saying um and
that means we don't see it in the data
right so for to guess uh how often
people breathe uh based on a web crawl
we would probably get it wrong um and we
also see effects like racism and sexism
and ableism and nationalism Express
expressed throughout um which reflects
just basic human behavior right so these
biases uh then have a ripple effect
throughout the rest of model development
as the training data itself is the only
information that a supervised uh machine
learning model can learn can learn
from um other kinds of human biases are
then layered on top of this and injected
into model development by the choice of
model the choice of the objective
function how the model is evaluated um
these choices persist in the rest of the
model life cycle so for example there's
the default effect which is going with
whatever is default uh for the model
you're developing and assuming it is
appropriate so this happens in our model
architecture choices um although you
know this talk about Transformers these
talks about Transformers are sort of
showing what happens when you move
outside of that default effect which
until Transformers were largely you know
sort of recurrent
structures um but it's also so things
like our optimization choices and then
this is even more true in applied
product context where it's used in
different kinds of context um there's a
similar effect of anchoring bias uh
which is sticking with what one is
familiar with so think of what your loss
function is right we don't tend to think
a lot about that unless we're
specifically writing a paper on that um
human biases are further injected into
any post-processing decisions or a lack
of post-processing right so just because
you don't think about it doesn't mean
that something isn't happening it just
means that you are making the choice to
have whatever is in there as a bias
persist as a bias um and this is also
where things like congruence bias comes
in confirmation biases um both are
biases where you tend to pay attention
to outcomes that are familiar to you and
leave out outcomes that aren't so that
means we need to do additional work in
development to Think Through the ways
that the model can affect different
people and this is a place where um risk
harms analysis is really
key um and finally once a model is
deployed people see the output and begin
to act on that output um but it's not
the end of the ml life cycle right so as
people act on the output um in the
outlets where the data is collected so
think about content moderation that you
see on YouTube on Facebook uh that you
know the recommendation systems you see
um in so many of the uh different apps
we use um that then that creates more
data as we interact with those systems
and then that becomes training data for
an updated model basically encoding uh
all of these biases essentially
permanently right so this creates an
echo chamber feedback loop where the
model then learns from the data that has
already encoded the biases in the first
model decisions and so this can amplify
problematic decisions over
time um I like I like to refer to this
as bias laundering um where the final
model can have all kinds of ethical
issues and it can be difficult to
pinpoint the exact sources uh that that
cause them um although it can be hard uh
it is part and parcel of the model uh so
really important to actually model and
factor in um I like to call this bias
laundering also because it allows me to
use this gift it is one of the only
gifts I had made by myself and I'm very
proud of it um I just read that when
women make jokes in talks it reflects
poorly on them so uh I guess I'm
reflecting poorly to everyone apologies
okay so the input data set defines what
we care about for the model uh the
default approach to development is to
Simply use the training data that is
available in a specific specific data
set and to evaluate on the evaluation
data that is available in that data set
right so if critical aspects of the
problems space aren't represented in the
pipeline then deploying the model means
you are making the value judgment that
these aspects should not be represented
so if the data the training the
post-processing creates models that
disproportionately under perform on some
populations you are implicitly making
the value judgment that some populations
should receive worst performance right
so machine learning development isn't
value neutral you can just uh for lack
of a better word be ignorant about those
values in your development um and what
this means is that we have to think
critically about values encoded
throughout development if our goal is to
in is to advance more human aligned more
ethics of informed kinds of artificial
intelligence um so this brings us to the
role of of Ethics in Ai and the role of
values so ethics doesn't provide an
answer uh but rather it provides
Frameworks for analyzing problems um in
light of different human values so uh
some example human values are shown on
the right uh and these are exactly the
values that can be incorporated not only
within the development pipeline um but
within the development culture more
broadly so having a basic understanding
of the major ethical theories will help
us in learning how to articulate and
justify our decisions so let's dive a
bit more deeply into the ethical
theories that can drive the production
of AI
systems so broadly speaking there are
four main families of Ethics meta ethics
and descriptive ethics are concerned
with uh analyses of Ethics in and of
itself uh normative is concerned with
the Norms the standards the criteria
that Define principles of ethical
Behavior Uh these are what provide the
tools for ethical analyses and
development um and applied ethics are uh
essentially ethical theories realized in
practice and within ethics uh informed
development in a technology company this
would correspond to something like the
organizational ethics or the
organization's
principles um one of the key ideas here
is that we all have different senses of
morality we have different cultures and
religions that prioritize different
kinds of values uh so for example
respect and honor for family uh tends to
be relatively under represented in
Western philosophy um but when we're
working within an organization these
values need to be defined at the
organization level in order to provide a
common ground of values that employees
can build off of and base uh different
decisions on so there's often this
question of who ethics right like it's
so hard to decide there has to be one
and it has to be one that we all agree
on but that's not right the question of
whose ethics is simply it's the
organization's ethics and every
organization will be different you can
think of this as a a business
differentiator or maybe a grad school
differentiator whatever it is um uh and
these ethics these values can be defined
by calling together the values from all
different
sources um including all the people who
have been hired right um so
uh there is not one good ethics there's
not one way to say this is ethical and
this is not it's all a function of the
people there and what the values they
prioritize are all right I hope that
makes sense um so as a vehicle for
operationalizing ethics uh within a
larger development pipeline or within an
organization normative ethics in
particular uh provide several different
perspectives uh so at a high level um
these p these perspectives concern
standards of
criteria um there are three main
theories um I'm probably doing a
horrible job I'm not an ethicist by
training but I've very much tried to
learn ethics uh within AI um so these
are things like virtue
consequentialism uh deontological ethics
um and in the context of Ethics informed
organizational
processes uh we are largely following a
deontological ethics that has been
informed by virtue ethics and uh
consequentialism um so let's turn again
to our pipeline uh where we earlier
highlighted how different problematic
Behavior can be propagated and Amplified
in a
model um in the collection of data this
first bit um values of concern include
copyright consent Fair pay diversity and
the right to something like contestation
the right to say that you don't want to
be in the data um currently the
state-of-the-art on all of this is
terrible um so generally copyright uh is
not a large part of what's taken into
account during uh data development
consent
is largely absent at least the sort of
informed consent that we would want uh
for people whose data is being used for
training models uh Fair pay often it's
no pay so you know that sucks um and we
generally fail at diversity in part
because the culture around machine
learning looks to get annotations as if
the production of annotations is some
black box where you throw in what you
want annotated and you get it back
ignoring that everything that happens in
that process uh brings with it tons of
different uh biases and what countries
this is happening in is really going to
affect uh what kinds of annotations
you're going to to get okay um and then
in model training values of concern
include how appropriate uh different
decisions are in light of the
foreseeable effects of the model right
so you have to think about how this will
be used in context will these people
know what a decision threshold is and
how to change it based on what they want
to do usually not um and so it's very
critical to Think Through how these
models will be applied in practice um
and in post-processing values include
the consideration of tradeoffs um and
aiming towards fairness of
outcomes um so we can now further
examine what these ethical values mean
uh within this First Data stage um and I
would say defining values in data
collection and annotation is one of the
most pressing issues in technology
currently um questions of who owns the
data whether it can be deleted what sort
of profit or benefit can be derived from
it all come into
play um and I like to call this the data
bottleneck because it's a touch point of
information flow um from Human thought
to AI but it's the source of an
incredible amount of
issues so in particular there is not a
way to have something like the most
values right or the most ethical thing
there are trade-offs and tensions in all
decisions and so it goes back to the
organization s uh or or the individuals
uh maybe if you're working alone um what
your defined values are um and PRI what
your prioritization is among them um so
for example we may want to release a
data set to help with bench marking and
reproducibility but this comes with the
tradeoffs of lack of informed consent
perpetuating problematic ideas that um
that are there without consent um and
the fact that the data can't
realistically be deleted yet we don't
yet have a state-of-the-art where we can
remove data um this means details of
individuals in the data can not only be
shared but continually Amplified and
proliferated without their consent right
there's the sort of misunderstanding
that well if it's out there it's already
public so we can use it the problem is
one instance being public and sort of
generally difficult to access is
different than being uh spread all over
the world to hundreds and thousands of
people these two things are not the same
um and so you know in the effort uh in
the efforts to have benchmarking and
repid disability we're often making the
choice to amplify and proliferate
problematic content without
consent um we may also want to aim for
things like inclusion and diversity
within our data uh representing
different people with respect to their
different norms and um but this comes up
against things like
exploitation uh and tokenism and
stereotyping um that's when data is
collected with a specific goal of
diversity By ignoring sort of all the
other factors at play um it's not yet
clear what the best methods are um but
there's uh still a lot of work to be
done and at least doing somewhat better
so I'll give you an
example um a couple years ago Google was
working working on face verification
phone unlock um uh for the pixel and
hired a vendor because they needed more
photos of black people so what did the
vendors do they went to a homeless camp
in Atlanta and paid people there who
were black
$5 for their face to build Google's
diverse uh facial recognition system
that you know obviously they would make
a lot of profit from so uh a few issues
there one is equ equating black people
with homeless people um so that's some
sort of disgusting stereotype I don't
think I was even aware of but there you
go uh exploiting people obviously $ five
and without uh very informed consent um
and also tokenism where you're not
looking at how to include this person in
light of what their General life is like
their culture everything else like this
uh but actually just focusing on who you
could quickly get because of this single
characteristic that's
tokenism right so one of the key
solutions to operationalizing ethical
data development means defining values
and priorities upfront and constructing
data specifically based on the values um
so this massively expands what it means
to collect and work with data making
data collection itself a detailed and
nuanced process with dedicated roles to
handle different aspects of dat data
development and uh corresponding
artifacts that allow the values encoded
in data selection to be further examined
throughout the pipeline and then within
final uh release
decisions so this can be seen as a life
cycle for the data as a whole um as it
requires continual monitoring and
analyses of the effects of the data and
updates then based on these
analyses um now we can turn to the
details of operational
I can just interrup you one second we
have a question that's very relevant on
the
data and which is how do we push for
adaptation of more ethical data sets not
imaginate cc4 Lon for example in major
conferences yeah so obvious maybe not
obviously so a lot of
researchers um have increasingly been
paying attention and a subset of
researchers have been publishing papers
on this so ABA ban has done incredible
work on this uh Jesse Dodge has led some
amazing work on this for um C4 right so
the fact that these papers are starting
to get accepted is a massive step
forward in sort of this General
understanding um they were not they were
largely rejected you know two years ago
uh so there's been an increase already
and understanding why these things are
important uh in part because of you know
the small subset of rers really
researchers really crying out for it
over and over again um and making it
clear via not only papers but Twitter
and blog posts and interviews and you
know so this is sort of happening now
the key now is to make sure that
reviewing rubric actually cares about
this stuff so uh when you're reading a
paper that talks about model training
and model evaluation you have to know
critical aspects of what that data set
for training is what that data set for
evaluation is and if it's too much to
include in the paper you can have it in
the appendix whatever it is but while we
continue to uh you know really celebrate
papers that don't discuss the data
they're using at all we're not going to
be incentivizing ethical data practices
um so reviewing rubric uh also Awards I
have this I have this idea that you can
get an award at a conference for like
best
evaluation uh or like best analysis of
input data or something like that
currently we have best paper Awards uh
which are it's pretty underspecified and
tends to uh bias in in certain ways but
once we can start breaking this down
into what we really want uh both in
terms of reviewing rubric and awards
then I think we can really get
somewhere thanks for that that makes
sense um cool um I didn't see the
question so I guess I'm not like in the
right chat or whatever but cool um so uh
the next bit here in this uh model sort
of pipeline is the model training um and
that's where values um come into play
around the appropriateness of the loss
function uh and the
model
so okay so I'm going to talk about this
via a case study um I was able to work
on uh Corona virus forecasting um which
was you know amazing to be able to work
on um and we quickly found that there
were a mass amount of modelbased
decisions that could drastically affect
people when the model was deployed so um
if you're not technical bear with me I'm
going to try and explain if you are this
might be just a repeat um but this is
very important so false positives in a
Corona virus forecasting model means
that hos hospitals might be OV equipped
expecting a need for more beds and
ventilators but a false negative means
that there would be less resources than
needed which could end in death right so
there are tradeoffs in different kinds
of errors but arguably a model that
tends towards false positives is
preferable to a model that tends towards
false
negatives and one of the issues at play
is the choice of loss function um so if
you take a look at the different kinds
of objectives that can be used which are
on the um bottom left um they treat
positive and negative instances the same
way these are all measured in terms of
absolute values right and so that means
positive false positive false negative
these basic ideas are to treated as
equivalent and so for the value aligned
goals of the model this suggests that
some additional work may be necessary
for the selection of the most suitable
model model um and uh perhaps
unsurprisingly trying to bring this
forward at Google mostly meant hostility
and it was a terrible experience now I'm
telling all of you still important even
if people are mean okay so moving on we
come to the post-processing and final
evaluation and so here too it's critical
to Think Through different types of
outputs and errors in order to select
the most suitable metrics to measure
model performance um and it's it's in
this stage that Concepts like fairness
diversity and inclusion are really
important um some of these are more
developed than others uh so let's talk
about them a
bit um so for those of you who are not
deeply familiar with fairness um one of
the most basic ways to think about
fairness um is in terms of a confusion
Matrix so what we have here um are a 2
by is a 2 by two two of references the
ground truth the thing that's actually
there and model predictions the thing
that the model is guessing um when
something exists and it's predicted
that's a true positive when something
doesn't exist and it's not predicted
that's a true negative the error types
we really care about when we're talking
about fairness um are false positives
and false negatives so these falses
right so if it doesn't exist but it is
predicted that's a false positive uh if
it exists and it's not predicted that's
a false
negative um but in one case uh a false
me a false negative may be better than a
false positive and in another case a
false positive might be better than a
false negative um so it's very critical
to to Define what kind of fairness you
care about as the equality of
essentially false negatives across
different groups equality of essentially
false positives across different groups
when you have these equalities based on
these kinds of errors this is what we
mean when we talk about fairness um so a
case where false positives would be
better than false negatives is something
like privacy and images um so a false
positive here something gets blurred um
that shouldn't be blurred that's just
sort of usually a bummer uh but a false
negative could be something that that
needs to be blurred not getting blurred
so that's like identity theft uh so we
clearly have uh a decision to make in
our model development which kind of
Errors we want to focus on um and by
thinking through in context it's clear
that in a situation like this we want to
make sure to minimize false
negatives um false negatives can be
better than false positives uh in
something like spam filtering uh so here
an email that spam is not caught so you
just see it in your inbox um usually
that's just a bit annoying um a false
positive email flag the spam is removed
from your inbox so if it's from a friend
or a loved one or it's a job opportunity
uh that's a loss right but note that the
usage in context really really matters
here so if foreseeable users include
those that are easily scammed leading to
a loss of wealth then false negatives
have a greater risk and model
development needs to balance these
different populations in determining the
optimal models the current
state-ofthe-art
nothing so low hanging fruit we can do a
lot
better um okay cool um so finally uh
people see the output uh in this process
and uh it begins again as people
interact with this output and then the
biases uh are further encoded uh and
more deeply ingrained in the
model um I'm not sure how I am on time
because I started a little
early um I can go you have time if you
yeah so I want to have time for
questions um let's I have questions
right now if you want I can ask I have a
few questions right now yeah yeah what
I'll do is I'll just kind of like wrap
this up really quickly um and then we
can go to questions um yeah so here's
some basic steps forward um and this is
sort of what I would like you guys to
remember if you take anything from this
talk um so uh we need to align
considerations of our own values to this
larger group that we're working in these
stated values um thinking through uh if
the technology should exist at all um by
using this sort of analysis of
foreseeable harms and risks by the
expected populations by the people who
will be affected by the model and how it
will be used in
context
um uh establishing basic organ
organizational values can be informed by
things like virtue ethics
consequentialism deontological ethics
where things like privacy fairness
Justice consent all these things come
into play and then can inform you know
what we prioritize as we
develop um once we start establishing
these things as intentional processes
throughout the pipeline requiring
artifacts and documentation um we can
start to be able to foresee uh even more
potentially problematic outcomes and
make more informed decisions on
releases um this goes to the question uh
earlier one of the critical ways to make
this move forward is incentivizing
ethics inform formed development um so
this is things like what gets uh put in
review rubric what kind of awards we get
at um what sorts of things um are uh
rewarded when they're talked about um
and one method I've worked on to capture
much of this uh is model cards um a
large part of why I joined hugging face
is because they were trying to come up
with ways to scale model cards and I
thought I could help um but it's
essentially an artifact to report sort
of all of the
above um and finally throughout uh the
critical critical most serious thing
that you can do uh is encourage and
reward foresight thinking through the
outcomes with different people in
different contexts and here's here's
what's important to know some people are
good at this and some people are bad at
this so if you're bad at this don't say
we can't develop AI with foresight just
accept that maybe some people have a
strength in this and you don't right um
I've been corrected that instead of
foresight uh what's more important is
rapid hindsight no some people are good
at foresight let them uh stop you from
having the need for Rapid hindsight
right um so this requires placing people
in the appropriate roles to make this
aspect of development really shine okay
thank you I'm done appreciate
it thanks a lot for your talk Meg it was
very
insightful um so I have a few questions
that were asked on the Forum uh let me
pick the first one um
so how do we process how do we protect
ourselves against machine Learning
System designed primarily without ethics
in mind because well obviously algorithm
being run out in the world right now and
uh
yeah yeah I
mean this is a really hard thing to
answer um I previously thought that part
of the solution was to um make sure that
the development that has already taken
place uh is retrofitted as much as
possible um so taking a look at the
kinds of evaluation data sets that were
used the kinds of training data sets
that we use doing uh more further
analysis into what errors it makes and
then essentially fine-tuning updating
the model based on that um unfortunately
I think in part because of this issue
where a lot of people in ml in ml are
just not that great at foresight uh and
don't really see the point of it um we
we're going to need regulation um so
that's that's sort of what it I think it
comes down to at this point makes sense
um another question that was bit too
long so I'm going to read the the last
part from The Forum so model
transparency seems to be aition
precondition of the mentioned ethical
goals Dr Mitchell seems to emphasize the
role of input data isn't the model's way
of decision making equally important uh
featuring important EX
for
um uh equally important um I would say
all of the above is important I'm not
sure how to extract that to numerical
values to to say that it's that it's a
quality um but uh one of the reasons why
I do have a focus on transparency is
because it's incentivization of good
practices throughout right so if you
have to report uh how your model does
all these errors then you're probably
not going to release it unless it does
well uh so as soon as you have
transparency this is a way to
essentially incentivize good practices
throughout um input data I do have a
focus on in particular because it tends
because it's what the model knows it's
it's the mo the the model's knowledge
Source um so there's so much that can be
said about evaluation and all these
other things but the issues very much
Start um with uh what What's in the data
um so I would say that's that's a
highest priority
yeah and then speaking of data uh what
about retraining models that are already
trained on unethical data is it possible
to fix them somehow yeah so I mean by
unethical data I'm taking that to mean
uh you know data that that has a lack of
consent data that our licenses and
copyrights are are not being paid
attention to data with pii um so I'll
assume uh that's what you mean by
unethical data um I I do think it makes
a lot of sense to to retrain and
fine-tune and actually some of the work
that I've done um has been specifically
on on bias mitigation techniques and
identification of stereotypes and things
like this um whether it's sort of
ethical to retrain um I guess that's
better than not retraining if it's going
to be deployed so I guess it depends on
the context that you're in if you're
writing a thesis maybe this will become
your topic of how to start from scratch
if you're in an organization and you're
retrofitting maybe the best way is to to
retrain or fine tune a bit um so I think
it depends a little bit on on context um
yeah I I guess that's that's the sort of
most relevant answer I have to that okay
lots of questions about debiasing like I
have another one here while training the
pr model is it possible to add a step
including debiasing algorithm are
emerging algorithms today could this
make some interesting bias
disappear um um yeah so so there's a lot
of work to be done in data that has tend
to be not incentivized there's also a
lot of work to be done in models and
this and this has been more incentivized
um and so I just want to make clear I
guess that one of the cool tricks is
around uh sort of multitask learning um
so uh bias mitigation techniques that
that tend to work um you know reasonably
well have to do with predicting a few
things at once and then uh discouraging
one thing while encouraging another so
for example say that you're trying to
predict whether or not um someone should
get promoted at the same time you can
predict gender and if you find that the
promotion decision um is predictable via
the gender then you know that you have a
bias system that's biased for gender so
one of the adversarial mitigation
techniques um that you know that's
pretty fun and there's a couple papers
on this
um I wrote one uh Alex gel uh let a
really cool paper on this is you
essentially um invert the gradient so
you predict both and for everything it's
learning about gender you say the
opposite of that you essentially
multiply by negative one and back back
propagate right so that says like you
don't know what gender is you don't and
you just tell the model until it's
essentially random um and that's really
a cool way of sort of removing a gender
bias there's other things you can do
with like pairing
um but but a lot of the key techniques
are around uh just this like having two
or more things that you're modeling at
once and encouraging one while
discouraging
another that's a very cool technique
indeed um another question let me scroll
a little bit uh yeah there might not be
a magical solution but what's the
easiest way to determine whether a text
generation model is not racist or sexist
and how do we solve this quickly without
losing M of training data solving it
quickly huh
yeah yeah I mean obviously as quickly as
possible is good if if there's sexist
and racist things in the world so you
know fair enough um so I think that it's
I don't know that it'll ever be possible
to have a model that's not sexist or not
racist because I don't know that it's
ever possible to have a person who's not
sexist or racist right I mean these are
all sort of based on humanistics and how
our our brains work as as we were
brought up and so um part of you know
going through like Ally training and you
know these kinds of things means that
you have to recognize it and uh
proactively address the kind of patterns
that you tend to do um so you would
imagine that similarly for a model you
would put in place normative constraints
like you do with people uh so that means
saying that um you know we are going to
mask gender so there's no distinction
between gender when we're training our
toxicity model
and so when we have an input gender we
we have no no way of handle we don't
know what it is right um and so so we
won't correlate the two and toxicity um
actually like particularly has a bias um
towards the term gay and and lgbtq terms
um so there are things you can do like
masking those or adding more data anywh
who um the point here is that um we can
put in place specific normative
constraints based on our social
knowledge so this is where social
scientists come in sociologists come in
on how racism and sexism and things like
this are expressed so we can do that and
that's definitely like a quick fix um
but a full-on fix might might not be
possible um but you know yeah do do as
much as you can
definitely another question around the
the bias in data is how could we balance
the filtering of bias between freedom of
speech and offensive bias consent oh
that's such a good question yeah I've
been struggling with this because um
ideally we can ground AI development in
like fundamental rights or human rights
um but if you are American Centric then
freedom of speech is like you consider
that like a fundamental right right but
like in other places uh like privacy is
nice or like you can imagine freedom
from discrimination as to be a cool
thing um or perhaps a basic right that
people should have uh but that you know
comes in conflict with the with the free
speech thing um so I mean I think part
of the issue here is that when you say
free speech um there's there tends to be
an assumption that there is some sort of
uniform sampling over all data instances
so that Free Speech as a whole is is
reflected so you have like people
talking about women positively and
people talking about women negatively
and so it's all free speech we want it
all um but what in fact happens is that
um the data sets tend to be heavily
biased towards men and using um and
using sources where there's misogyny so
like Reddit um and that is not
counteracted by free speech about uh
women being awesome or whatever uh so um
so yeah I mean like one of the things
about free speech that that is kind of
fun to do is actual data collection so I
was part of a project uh called project
respect that went to like gay pride
parades and and had people say like
really proud things about their identity
and their uh you know uh their lgbtq
like associations and stuff like that
and that created like tons of data that
we can use in training a toxicity model
um that's a lot of work and you have to
have willing participants and hopefully
compensate them whatever they should be
paid um but um but yeah I mean it's
there there's a few things you can do
but keep in mind
that the Free Speech
idea is a little bit hampered by the
fact that the free speech that we
collect is is biased and tends to be
more misogynistic and and racist than
maybe a larger sample would
have yeah definitely and around like the
the compensating participant for
creating the data I have another
question which is is making it mandatory
enforcing to create data sets where each
participant is highly paid going to put
a lot of pressure on researchers from
low resource institutions and researcher
from low resources countries yeah that's
a really good question um I think this
is where things like um governments
start to play a role um
and it's it's I think it's also kind of
important to note that this also is very
destructive to private companies that
are um that have you know a lot of money
so um it's sort of like I sort of feel
like the larger the organization the
more this will hurt them right so if um
for example you require Google to pay
everyone for the data they're producing
um Google you know Google's business
model would be basically destroyed um so
you know in some ways we might think of
methods where different compensation
tiers you know make make sense for
different kinds of organizations you
could get this via regulation so you
know if if you're a grad student um
paying you know a minimum wage or
whatever for your annotations um that's
that's pretty reasonable that's pretty
normal um if you're you know a
multi-billion dollar Corporation um
perhaps paying a lot more is is
worthwhile uh especially because like
you're making profit off of this so it
should be a percentage of that profit in
some way um so I think there are ways
not to over disadvantage um uh low
resource uh
groups um or or organizations um and I
think that it could go the other way
like very much harming larger private
companies and one last question which is
a bit more personal is what does the
regular day-to-day work look like for
you oh well so I just joined hugging
face full-time on November 1st um and
before that I was doing like a lot of
Contracting and Consulting and so I've
just been sort of all over the place I'm
someone who wears many hats like I like
talking about philosophy and then I like
talking about statistics and then I like
coding and then I like writing and uh so
I really don't think I have a
traditional day uh I will say that I
hate waking up before 900 amm Pacific
time and so presenting at 9:30 was a
feat I hope I seem coherent um I think
that's that's basically the only the
only standard throughout my day the only
common thing is that I try and not get
up until 9: um but other than that yeah
I jump around between coding and
thinking through math stuff and writing
papers and reading papers and sometimes
answering email sometimes yeah
sometimes well thanks a lot for for your
time this morning because this was super
interesting talk and very insightful
answers to all the questions awesome
thank you
guys and uh I'll at Le res introduce our
next speaker while I say bye to Margaret
Mitchell
sure so I'll just add Chen and Matthew
hey guys how you going I think Chen
you're on mute hey he so so this is uh
Matthew and uh Chen they're from um the
Caris team um and Matthew is a machine
learning engineer um who focuses on High
level modeling apis and he studied
computer Graphics dur an undergrad and
has a masters from Stanford and uh Chen
is a software engineer from the Caris
team who who also focuses on these high
level modeling apis um and also has a
masters in electrical engineering from
Stanford and is really interested in
simplifying code implementations of ml
tasks um so we're really excited to to
have you here to sort of help people
understand kind of what carus is you
know maybe convert all the pie torch die
hards um and before getting started I
just want to um show people um just
quickly how they can ask questions so if
you go to the hugging face forums um you
can click on the course um category and
then you can scroll down to where we
have Matthew Watson and Chen and here
you can just post your questions and
we'll be voting on them based on likes
and then and also the the forums contain
the links to the to the collab notebooks
that Matt and Chen is are going to
use cool so with that I think uh Matt
you're first right yeah I'll be first so
we'll um add your screen and um yeah
we'll uh see you soon okay great um yeah
let
me actually start the
presentation um okay cool yeah thanks
for joining um yeah I'm I'm Matt and I'm
speaking with Chen we're both on the
Caris team inside of tensorflow um and
yeah today we're going to be talking to
you about NLP workflows inside of the
Caris
Library um so quick just kind of plan
for the day I'm going to do the first
part of this talk and I'm going to be
just talking about kind of building like
very basic models very basic NLP models
inside of Caris and showing showing what
that looks like um then I'll hand it
over to Chen who's going to talk about
kind of like pre-training and
fine-tuning using hugging face and Kos
um hopefully all of that will take about
half an hour and then we'll have
questions um cool so before I even dive
into my side of the talk I wanted to do
two slides like super quickly just
giving an introduction to to Caris to
anyone who hasn't seen this before um so
yeah first off what is Caris um it is a
deep learning API um and the kind of
one- sentence version of it is deep
learning for humans um but what that
that means in terms of how we're trying
to build our library is really centering
it around like simple apis that kind of
reduce cognitive load as you're building
up your models so you can focus on
building your models um and really
trying to focus on kind of a minimal
number of actions that you need to take
for common use cases so basically you
can get the Caris library and spin up a
lot of examples very quickly start to
kind of explore your problem space very
quickly that's a key goal with the Caris
libraries um and then another way you
can think about it is caras is the
highle modeling and training apis that
will come prepackaged with tensor
flow um so yeah that's Caris uh and then
I wanted to also introduce just two kind
of basic abstractions that you'll run
into over and over again with the caros
library and that's layers and models um
so yeah you you might be you might have
seen something familiar to this
somewhere but basically you can think of
layers as kind of these Lego blocks of
like common motifs that you'll see in
many machine learning model
architectures um and with Caris you can
take these Lego blocks you can combine
them in a whole lot of expressive ways
um and then yeah snap them together and
a model will be this collection of
layers the kind of map from your inputs
to outputs and the model is the going to
be the thing that you can like train
that you can save that has all these
highly level apis available on
it okay so that was a super super quick
introduction to Caris the library as a
whole um now I'm going to do my my side
of the talk that's on these kind of
basic NLP models we can build with Caris
um and I'm going to be doing this with
the sentiment analysis data set from
IMDb if you haven't seen this I think
it's like 25,000 reviews in the training
data set that are just movie reviews
like three or so paragraphs of text
describing a movie and we're just trying
to build a model that will predict is
this a positive review or a negative
review um and my my goal in showing all
this is going to first be to just kind
of show some basic building blocks for
Caris um working with Tex and Caris um
and then the main kind of the thesis of
my side of the talk is going to be about
this this triangle on the right hand
side here which is the but using Caris
you can hopefully go very quickly from
an idea to an experiment to seeing some
results um and use that to inform kind
of the next experiment you run in a nice
tight Loop so we'll actually build up
like four very quick models on on my
side of the
talk okay um so we're gonna be writing
this all in code so let's let's start by
downloading our data set um yeah you can
see what we're doing here is we're first
just downloading a a bunch of plain text
files in a couple directories and then
we're going to use a Caris utility to
load them as a tensorflow data set um
and yeah we're batching things and when
when data is flowing through tensorflow
you're going to be seeing everything
going through as tensors that's kind of
how tensorflow works and you can see
once we've loaded our data set and
batched it we have these batches of size
32 where every input we have just a
single input feature coming in for each
of our examples which is a string I I've
truncated it here because they'd be too
long to show reasonably on a slide but
think each string is you know many
paragraphs of text and then each label
is a one or a zero and a one here means
this is a positive review a zero means
it was a negative
review Okay so we've download our dat
set you kind of immediately hit this
roadblock that you'll you know hit every
time in NLP which is how do we represent
our data um you're not going to feed
strings directly into any neural network
architecture so you know you need some
sort of transformation of your input
before you can even really start
worrying about your model
architecture um and one approach that
you can use inside the carass library
for this is the text vectorization layer
which we'll see in code in a second um
but yeah it's it's one of our Lego
blocks that's kind of just centered
specifically around working with text
input um so it'll do a few different
steps they're they're all configurable
but by default it'll have a
normalization stage where you'll remove
punctuation and lowercase um a splitting
stage and the I think the default option
will just split on whites space so
splitting into different words um and
then there's a number of different ways
you can map from from that idea of
string tokens to some sort of numeric
inputs for your
model and the the simple model the first
thing that we're going to build you may
have seen this before it's called a a
unigram model you'll also see this
called a bag of words model um and yeah
it's a it's a nice simple thing we can
build to start trying to guess if our
reviews are positive or negative where
we're essentially just going to look at
what words are present in a review and
what words are not present in a review
so we're going to build up this
vocabulary of the most common words in
all our reviews first um and then when
we get around to kind of encoding each
individual review we're going to encode
each individual review as this big long
array of zeros and ones that kind of
aligns with our vocabulary that we've
learned and if you get a one that means
that word was present in your bag um so
the word movie is present in this review
we get a one at that movie index good is
not present we get a zero um so that's
the rough idea for the model that we're
going to build let's look at this in
code um yeah this is actually a complete
training example for this unigram model
but I'll try to break this down step by
step so first off like kind of the
overall flow that we're doing here is
we're going to Define this kind of
symbolic input at the top which is
saying that we have you know our our
inputs are a single feature it's a
single element string that's going to be
coming through then we're going to
transform our inputs with some layers
it's two of these Lego blocks that we're
going to snap together um to transform
our inputs to outputs we build a model
over our inputs and outputs and then we
train that model um so that's that's the
rough flow um and then we can step
through these two kind of blocks here
the first first thing here is probably
the most dense which is the
pre-processing um and this is where
we're going to use that text
factorization layer we talked about so
first thing we're doing here because
we're for a second we're just going to
be working with our our features and not
our labels is we're going to map over
our data set we're going to toss out the
label just to give us the the plain
reviews alone in a data set um then
we're going to build our first Caris
layer and you can see when you're
building a Caris layer you normally will
initialize these with some amount of
configuration as to how they're supposed
to work um so this output mode multi hot
is where we're asking for this bag of
words en coding of our input and then
this Max tokens 10,000 is just saying
how big do we want our vocabulary to be
and we're saying we want to learn the
10,000 most frequent words um in all of
our reviews and the way we actually
learn the 10,000 most frequent words you
could actually apply a vocabulary
yourself if you knew that and you had
trained it yourself um but you can also
use this utility function that we have
called adapt which is actually going to
Loop over all of our features all of our
input reviews and just learn the 10,000
most common words that we see in all
reviews um so when we've learned our
vocabulary we're ready to actually call
the text vectorization layer on our
inputs Caris layers when you want to
call them you can just treat them as
functions and call them on your input
and that will give us this bag of words
representation that we just talked about
um so from there then we actually still
need to build a trainable model on top
of this um and the simplest thing we can
think of to do there is kind of just add
a linear layer on top of this and we'll
just call it a day there so we're gonna
yeah we we're mapping each of our inputs
to this 10,000 long array of ones and
zeros and we're just going to learn a
linear combination of all of those
10,000 values pass that through a
sigmoid function and that's our whole
model um so yeah just logistic
regression on top of our bag of words um
yeah so once we've done that we can
Define our model uh compile is a cars
function on models for just kind of
setting up how your training is going to
work um so we can specify our loss
function here we can say we want to
track accuracy here and then we just
train for five
epics um so yeah that's a complete code
example in Caris I encourage you to try
this out in a collab if you would like
um
but yeah essentially now we've we've
built our first model and we've kind of
made two design choices here we've made
a design Choice around how we want to
represent our input data as some sort of
numeric input um and then how do we want
the actual trainable architecture of our
model to look and now we're now that
we've built up our first example we're
just going to iterate on a few different
ideas for how how we can build up our
model for the rest of for the rest of my
part of the
talk um so take one was what we just did
unigram model we're taking in our input
reviews we're mapping it to a bag of
words where we're throwing out all of
our sequence data we're throwing out
everything except just what words were
present what words were not present we
don't even care how many times the word
film appears we just want to know is it
in the review or not um so this is the
exact code I showed you before I've just
kind of zoomed in on the actual meat of
the model here because we're going to
just be iterating on this for the rest
of the talk um but what does this look
like when you actually run it how does
it perform um first thing you can notice
here is that it's a very small models
that we're actually training it's just
10,000 parameters because we're just
learning a weight term for each term in
our vocabulary and that's it that's the
whole model um and we're actually
already doing pretty well we've got 89%
validation accuracy um on a whole that
data set
um so yeah that was that was take one um
and now we can start doing what
hopefully Caris is going to make it easy
to do which is iterate on a bunch of
different ideas kind of explore the
landscape of this little problem that
we're working on um so take two we can
try is a Bagram model um and byrams are
just fancy word for a pair of words
together so if you're looking at this
first sentence this film is a biogram in
this sentence a travesty is a biogram in
this sentence and we want to build the
exact same sort of bag of words idea but
we now also want to look at byrams in
addition to unigrams and you could think
how this might be useful already because
not good the Bagram not good means
something very different than the the
unigram good so by adding in that little
bit more knowledge of our kind of
sequence data coming in maybe we can
build a more expressive
model um so what does this look like in
code we actually have to just make very
very small changes to our text
vectorization layer this is the
pre-processing side of our model
definition um and we're just going to
make two changes here we're gonna one
we're going to just bump our vocabulary
size we've changed from looking at only
words to looking at words and pairs of
words so kind of a vocabulary space is a
lot bigger so we want to learn a bigger
vocabulary inside of that space um and
then this engrams 2 argument is just
where we ask ask the text factorization
layer to also look at byrams as well as
unigrams everything else stays exactly
the same we keep learning our logistic
regression on top and that is our entire
model so if you ran this in code you
would see okay we've bumped the
vocabulary size um from 10,000 to 20,000
parameters um just doubled our
vocabulary size so we've doubled our
model size um but we've actually bumped
our accuracy so now we're over 90%
accurate um predicting whether riew is
positive or negative so that's great it
was a nice quick and successful
experiment that we ran um and yeah now
we'll try two more models on this side
of the talk um and the first thing what
what we'll do for the next two models
that we build is we'll we'll switch from
we'll we'll say forget the bag we're not
going to do the bag of words model
anymore um and we're going to do this
very common thing in in NLP which is
we're just going to map each word to an
integer index um so we're keeping our
sequence data in our pre-processing and
we have this movie was bad this list
coming in we're going to map each
individual word to an index so this is
the fourth index in our vocabulary so
this maps to a four movie is the first
index it Maps 2011 and this output is
going to kind of be our pre-processed
inputs that we're working with for our
last two examples here
um okay so what can you do with integer
indices for Words the common thing
you'll do um in most models is embed
them so we're going to take our input
sequence we're going to take our input
string we're going to map it to a
sequence of integers and then we're
going to map each individual integer to
a set of trainable parameters so the
index 11 will map to in this example for
trainable parameters same with 20 um I'm
going to learn this big long kind of
horizontal embedding that you can think
of where we're just pulling out
individual columns for each word and
hopefully that learns like this Rich um
but low dimensional space for all the
words that we have coming in um and then
because we're just trying to keep our
model simple on this this side of the
talk we're going to do the simplest
thing we can think of with our sequence
of embedded Words which is just average
them together not even try to do
anything fancier than that
okay so let's dig into this in code um
we still have our pre-processing block
and the the part where we apply our
actual trainable layers the
pre-processing block is going to change
a little bit here um we're switching our
output mode so this is where we're
saying we don't want our bagged model we
actually do want a sequence of integers
coming out of our text vectorization
layer our vocabulary size will move to
10,000 and then output sequence length
this is just something to keep those
example simple where we're going to say
for every input review if it's less than
250 words we're just going to pad this
with zeros till it becomes 250 words and
if we get a review that's longer than
250 words we're just going to chop it
off at 250 words and that'll just keep
training simple here um and then for the
actual trainable model we have a good
bit of new stuff here um we're using our
embedding so this is where we take each
word and map it to an embedding for each
word um rather than for like on the
slide I was showing we're actually
mapping to 32 different trainable
parameters for each word um we apply
some Dropout and this is just because
we're building a much more expressive
model with a lot more parameters here so
it helps to bring in some Dropout just
to avoid overfitting and then we're
doing this very simple the global
average pooling 1D is really all it's
doing it's taking everything in your
sequences in your input data and
averaging them together um so we'll
build that model we'll still build a a
logistic regression on top just to map
everything to one single prediction um
and that's our whole model so if you
were to run this um you'd see we've kind
of exploded our parameter space a bunch
because our embedding is now it's pretty
big we have 320,000 parameters compared
to 20,000 for our simple uh bgram model
that we were looking at last time and
we've actually not improved our our
validation accuracy at all we've gone
from 90% with the Byram model to
87% um so maybe not the best line of
inquiry to keep going down further but
at least this was a quick experiment we
could run try out and see how it
works um okay and then the last kind of
model that we're going to build here is
a recurrent one and probably a lot of
people in the stock have seen this
before I won't go too deep into the
details of to recurrent neural network
works or anything but the idea is we're
going to build this lstm model do the
exact same Transformations as we were
doing before where we take our input
sequence we map it to a sequence of
integers for each word each word maps to
an integer we map each integer then to
an embedding for each word which is
hopefully this this low dimensional but
Rich representation of each word um and
then we feed all of those into this
recurrent neural network which is going
to be a trainable bunch of cells where
we process each word one at a time and
as we're processing the word our our
trainable cell will have some sort of
memory of what it's seen before so
hopefully the lstm can learn some
interesting things about our sequences
coming in and start to remember what
words it's seen a word what words it's
seen before a particular word that it's
looking at in a
sequence um so that's the idea what does
this look like um in terms of code we'll
we'll keep our input representation
exactly the same we keep our
pre-processing the same we keep our
embedding the same Dropout everything's
the same except we're just going to
switch out our pooling layer with a
trainable lstm layer and that will be it
um so if you ran this this is our most
expressive model um yeah we started with
a 10K parameter model and now we're at
336 parameters um and we're actually
doing the worst of all of them with our
biggest model um so we top out at about
86% validation accuracy and you can see
we're already really struggling with
overfitting um okay so that was a just
very quick introduction to what it looks
like to build four different simple NLP
models with Caris and again the rough
idea and what we're trying to do with
the library is to make it really easy to
run kind of experiments like this to
come up with some idea for either how
you represent your your input text um
but when you feed it into your model how
you pre-process it or an idea for how
you want to actually architect your
model itself and go very quickly from
that idea to some sort of results um so
yeah that's entirely what we're aiming
to do with the Caris API and you can
already see how it's it's given us some
useful information into our our problem
here where we've found this nice sweet
spot the endr models actually turn out
to be when you're not doing pre-training
and there could be a lot of reasons you
don't want to do pre-training in in a
problem like this um where you you know
we built a model with only 20,000
parameters that is going to be
incredibly computationally efficient
it'll give you really fast inference
times um and it's already greater than
90% accuracy so you can play with this
more certain you can get to even better
accuracy with with engram models but
we've already kind of found this nice
kind of sweet spot to to go dig into and
you could try this you could try more
things attention mechanisms um whatnot
but yeah that was just a quick quick
inro of trying a few different simple
architectures in car um but yeah if you
did want to get to like state-of-the-art
performance you'll want to do
pre-training and fine-tuning so for that
I will hand off to
Chen awesome thanks a lot Matt I'll add
Chen to the
stream um would you like us to do
questions for your section all together
at the end I think we're gonna just do
questions at the end if that do together
perfect thanks right I'm going to go
present here so I'm just gonna add uh
Chens slides great
so sounds good so take it away thanks
cool uh hi my name is Chen in the second
half of the talk I would like to
demonstrate with real Co examples on how
to do find training with huging face and
caras the main takeaway we hope you get
from this talk is you will find it
simple to Define training with ha caras
and the hugging
face we will use the same task as the
first half the IMDb sentiment analysis
in the second
part and some background for people not
familiar with fine training the idea is
starting halfway towards our Target
instead of building a model from scratch
it's pretty similar to buying a house
imagine you want to buy a house usually
we do not buy an empty land and build a
new house but we buy a house and do the
remodeling the remodeling process is
pretty similar to fine training idea and
in our IMDb sentiment analysis task we
can load a preure and burn model and
build out a model on top of
it and what is bird bird stands for bir
directional Inc representations from
Transformers it was published by Google
in 2018 and has gained great popularity
in I Community due to it strong
performance explanation on bird is
beyond the scope of this talk the main
thing we need to know is bird is very
good at extracting representations from
texts or say birth is a good text
encoder now let's take an overview of
the model architecture we are going to
build first of all we have the text
loaded from IMDb data sets the movie
reviews and we add a special token in
front of each movie named the CLS we
will come to the purpose of this token
very
soon the first layer we have is a bird
tokenizer as we mentioned in the first
half neural networks cannot understand
string input so we need to map this
sequence of into of text into a sequence
of integers it's a job of this bird
tokenizer the second layer is a bird
encoder it takes in the sequence of
integers and map it into a sequence of
vectors and here we only take the first
Vector the vector for the CLS token to
represent the whole sentence this is an
common RP practice basically if we set
up the model properly the information of
the sentence is going to be fused into
the first
token now we have the vector
representation we add a third layer the
fully connected layer to map the vector
into another space
which is usually of a smaller Dimension
we call a projected representation this
is going to be our final representation
for inut text and the last layer is
straightforward we inut this project
representation into a softmax classifier
the output would be the probability of
this movie review being positive and
being negative that's all for the model
before we look into a code I want to
pause here for a few seconds I want to
think about one question
like how complex do you think Mak the
model work is like like how many lines
of code do you expect to write or like
how many hours to expect to spend here I
want post here for like 10 seconds and
let you think about it just give it a
guess okay cool now with the answer in
your mind let's look at the code we have
in total five steps the first step is to
load the tokenizer and pre birth from
huging face Library as highlighted in
the r box if you haven't installed the
Transformer Library you need to copy up
install to install that and you pick up
the model you want to use and in our
case we pick up the B Ste bir tokenizer
fast and this Ste Bird model and if you
are not familiar with the input and
output format of the model you can play
around with it this is one sample
output and the second step is to load
IMDb data set into a memory this part is
pretty similar to the first half so I
will not jump into details of it but I
want to pause here for a few seconds to
let you look at the
code let's go to step three step three
is to tokenize the data set as
highlighted in the r box as we already
have the data and the tokenizer we can
simply inut the data into the token izer
output like train encoding validation
encoding would be the sequence of
integers we described
previously and we do one more conversion
we convert the data into the format of
tensorflow data set so it can be
understood by our
carow a minor detail here starting from
this tensorflow data set conversion
every code is going to be based on tens
FL and the caras
library now we are going to step four
build our text class ification model on
top of the pran bird to build a car
model you want to subclass the C model
class and because we are taking in an an
external bird encoder we want to add an
argument named the encoder into the AR
list of the Constructor and we
explicitly set the trendable field as
true so that the gradients can be back
propagated all the way towards the
preure and burn model the rest part is
straightforward we have fully connected
layer which is the self. dance one here
and we have softmax classifier which is
self. dance two here and the J is a
common practice to avoid over
fitting and remember to Chanel
components together by overwriting a
call method it's very simple you just
specify the output of a previous model
as the input to the next
modu and we are almost there last step
is to tr the model we want to First have
a model instance and some configurations
like what Optimizer will you use and
what's the loss functions you and some
matric you want to pay attention to and
you come mod of it to get a model
train and this is output of this model
training process we see that within two
epok we arrive at a validation accuracy
of around 92% which is good but we still
see the over fitting problems like say
EO 3 we see the training accuracy being
97% % but the Val accuracy is only 91%
this is because even though the addoms
like the fully connected ler is very
small but the birth itself is very big
so it has overfeeding problem and that's
all for the code and we have shared this
code in the Forum I would encourage you
to check it out and especially if you're
interested in buting this overfitting
problem you can use this code as a
starting point and write a code on top
of it and that's all for the talk we can
go to the question
session awesome thanks a lot Chen and
Matt for your really nice talks and
careful breakdown of caras um got a
couple of questions here some are a bit
technical um so one question is uh Matt
you explained this text vectorization
class yeah just this in the um here so
we can see it so you know it kind of
looks like a
tokenizer um in some sense and the
question is does it or caros the library
more generally allow users to kind of
train their own tokenizers so if they're
trying to sort of train BT themselves um
they do this yeah um that's a great
question tax factorization is going to
give you um just kind of more basic
tokenization so it'll be good if you
want to do like a character level
tokenization or a word level
tokenization um but if you want like B
most of these Transformer architectures
you're usually going to want subword
tokenization um which text factorization
won't do um but there is a library you
could check out called TF text um I mean
for one you could use the hugging face
tokenizers for sure there's also a
library called TF text um which you
could look at which will allow word
piece and sentence piece kind of inside
the tensorflow graph um which there
could be times where you want all of
basically your Transformations happening
inside the tensor flow graph so TF text
as a way you could do that awesome and
speaking of tensor flow the next
question is uh people tend to use tensor
flow and Kos
interchangeably and I was wondering what
the differences are or when when should
you use one over the
other um yeah I mean I think the way you
can kind of I mean tensorflow is a a
broad term for a large ecosystem but if
you think of the core tensorflow apis as
being yeah kind of a lower level Caris
is a higher level training IPI layered
on top of it um so they're not
interchangeable you can use tensorflow
without using Kos um but Kos is usually
the easiest way to build a model inside
right
yeah please I was just gonna say I think
tensorflow two kind of if I remember
correctly Kos became kind of like a
first class citizen is that correct yeah
that that this is not the case in tensor
flow one but the tensor flow that's the
the new picture how was about to say in
our initial launch of tensor FL two we
put car and tensor flow together so in
that case we have no difference between
that because you when you want to call
caras you just do TF car things and we
have split the code outside car outside
tensor flow the car Ripple is not
separate but mainly speaking like for
people building model the first place we
go to still using the caras because it's
like it has the layer and the model
obstruction there it's more closely
aligned with a building model
process yeah definitely I totally agree
like if you want to you know build an
experiment quickly you just want to just
get done fast you don't want to you know
get into the low level you know Gra and
stuff but I think you know from my old
experience in tens flow one using the
graph was really great for performance
reasons sure this is maybe more of a
philosophical question um so since the
Transformer architecture took over NLP
do you see a good use for previous
models like lstms because I think Matt
you showed a pretty nice example and you
kind of answered this a little bit with
this uh you know 20K pret or 90k
parameter model I think yeah I mean I
think it totally depends on your problem
set but in the example we looking at
like this it's a very small amount of
data and you might be worried about
being doing pre-training because maybe
you you know it's a lot of kind of extra
data to bring in it's hard to validate
you might be worried about bias um you
might be worried about computational
efficiency when you're doing inference
so in this example the lstms actually
weren't a great way to go down but the
engram models which are some of the like
simplest things you hit in like chapter
one of any NLP textbook are actually
really really performant and it's good
to remember they're out there if you do
want like a really simple model that you
can train that's surprisingly quite
effective yeah I totally agree I think
like one thing we sometimes forget is
like you know Transformers is not like
the first thing you should reach for
maybe like if if you're building like a
real NLP application naive Bay with
engrams is like a really strong Baseline
and you know you'll often find that the
extra complexity you know causes you
some problems in prod um let's see so
this is maybe a question for Chen um so
there's a lot of optimizers out there
these days and is Adam really all we
need or should we be looking at other
optimizers because I think you mentioned
in your code when you were building the
model. compile you had adom and yeah I
know that like there's like a history of
adom and Adam W and all these kind of
things but I'm just curious like just
generally what do you think about the
space of optimizers and yes where where
this is developing so that really
depends on what you want so if you want
to build a state of art Model Adam is
definitely not enough but if you want to
play around with a with a model want to
try some development work those atam is
good enough but one thing there even if
you are using Adam you may need to look
at something called moving average
Optimizer which is inside tens Adam it's
just like rap Optimizer but you keep the
moving average of the model variables so
that it gives you some boost in the
performance that's something you want to
look at but if you're looking at
building some state of ours model maybe
you can check out about something like
SC s Optimizer and some other like
Advanced strategy I I would say like
short answer is it still good but if
you're are looking on something very
Advanced you can think about some other
approach awesome let me just have a
quick look to see what else we have
here
um okay so another question we have
is in the chat give me a
sec so the question is um Can layerwise
learning rates help uh during fine
tuning when it comes to B
models uh the short answer is I think it
can but it will be really hard to
configure that probably you should try a
lot of times before you can actually get
the model converged because if you are
find training with not a b model it's
very aror problem if you set up like
some layer using a wrong learning rate
maybe of some problem problem but
definitely with at a high level it
should help with the F training process
but probably not in the aspect of doing
the the the speed of making this work
but just like performance the final
performance could be better yep yeah
totally agree um and this is another
final question maybe for Matt I think in
um your talk you you were explaining you
know you had these learning cures or the
validation um accuracy and so on and so
the question is can you expand a bit
more on this idea of training loss and
validation loss and if the validation
loss starts increasing can we conclude
that the model is
overfitting um yeah if your accuracy is
going down or your loss is going up on
your validation set that I mean you
things can be noisy and you want to look
at how much noisy but I mean in a lot of
our with the examples I was showing we
weren't doing any pre-training so we're
just looking at this very small data set
of 25,000 input examples um which is
it's really really easy to fit overfit
at least when you're looking at at an be
problems so yeah I'm pretty much all of
all of those simple models I showed if
you you keep trading for a while you
know notice that you start to be
overfitting a little bit awesome and
maybe I can ask the last question it's a
it's a personal one so um like you know
working at hugging face I you know
contribute to some of the open source
libraries we have here and there's
always this kind of like um trying to
keep an eye out on the future of like
you know where where things are going so
for example you know Transformers
there's a lot of developments outside of
NLP and one thing that um huging face is
interested in is like you know looking
at vision and audio and so you sort of
have to make some design decisions about
your library how it evolves and how do
you make sure things are backwards
compatible and I was kind of curious
like in the caros team like where do you
see like the sort of like the future
what are the interesting like say
domains or let's say even apis that you
find particularly exciting and maybe you
can shed some light on on where where
the library is
going
M do you want to talk about like car op
doing yeah I think well I think
one there there's a number of of things
that we're looking at at the Caris
Library um I mean I think one thing we
always continue to look at which
separate from from this kind of side of
the talk is just how do you easily
distribute stuff so I think one one
place we continue to have a lot of work
is like you you've written some simple
training example and you want to like
and as quickly as possible take it to
running on a bunch of machines um doing
a multi-work setting we're always
working on that um but yeah another part
that we're looking at a lot is yeah just
kind of bringing in more high level
abstractions for for NLP and CV um kind
of giving more kind of of these Lego
blocks that we kind of give you giving a
lot more that are specific to those
applications to hopefully make it a lot
easier to get get up and running with
kind of more complicated NLP models and
and CB models computer vision models and
one thing I want to add about
distributed training intens flow is we
are trying to make it like even more
simless currently you if you write this
distributor code in t FL need to call
some strateg things I think there is
some ongoing efforts trying to trying to
make that disappear like you are going
to write the same code which is called
D like I think it's going to like bridge
the gap between like Stand Out Long
training and distribut training and
hopefully that would be much easier in
the
future yeah that would be that would be
like awesome because I kind of feel that
like where we are now as a field
especially in industry is like there's
like a kind of like you know different
age of like finally you get gpus at your
company and you know like for example
like you know in my old job I was a data
scientist and you could get one GPU and
you had to share it you know with like
three data scientists um but you start
to see that like now that companies are
really investing heavily especially in
NLP that this idea of like distributed
training becomes really important
because you know being being able to
iterate fast is is in some sense like
the way you make progress on your
problem and yeah I I think at the moment
there's a lot of like pain in in like
you know if if you think to yourself
okay I've got my super nice say car us
you know loans of code you said it's not
so much code and now suddenly I want to
scale out to like you know 20 gpus and
then I I feel like the abstractions are
not quite there yet like at least for me
like I feel like it takes a lot of work
to to build out to that yeah definitely
an area where like and yeah I mean Caris
is really all about that idea the faster
you can iterate is the faster you can
like come up with interesting ideas so
we definitely want to be doing that in
the multi-worker
setting awesome so that's it for the
questions um and yeah thank you once
again for taking part in this community
event um it's I think it's given people
a really great primer for um how to
train models in in chos in tensor flow
and we have a tensorflow scapegoat as we
say at hugging phas who's you know
responsible for building all the API
part of Hing Transformers and he's super
excited to to see more people um using
this so thanks a lot cool thanks for
having thanks a lot for
joining hey so I think we have a few
minutes before the next speaker right
yes we finished a bit in advance the
previous talk and Matt and Chen were in
advance so we could begin vers in
advance
but wai it's rare to be ahead of time
right
usually exactly so maybe I could ask you
San um for people who are interested in
like doing projects uh for the you know
the next three days or the last three
days of this week kind of like you know
what should they know um about this and
a lot of people have been asking about
the certificate maybe we could talk
about that for the next few minutes yes
uh so that's very good idea thanks leis
so let me share my screen again um to
show you how to go on the forums so the
idea is that we'll use the form to
coordinate uh Team
project and here it is the form again so
if you go in the course
category you'll see that there is a
course project subcategory on which you
can click and then you can browse uh lot
of existing uh projects uh for instance
this one was Community contributed so
let's have a look at this one sorry leis
I'm not going to pick one of the one you
built uh but this is going to look like
this there is a small description of the
project uh there is a model suggestion
of to fine tune on that project there is
a suggestion of data set how to to scrap
it from the web or or to use an existing
one if it if it's on the on the PO
instance on the data set hubs where the
challenge is to excap to expect on this
project and what's the desired outcome
and um the idea is that that this
project should um uh go over find tuning
a model and then create a live demo of
it on a hugging face space so let me
show you qu very quickly what a face
space
is um it's kind of a demo uh of one
model so one that is very popular right
now is Animan V2 you may have seen some
of it on social media I won't be able to
show you live what it does because I'm
pretty sure there is a
queue uh but um it
loads it doesn't even
maybe yeah another nice demo would
be
um what was the one let me go through
the organization of
the is it for the course but you put it
but you put
your
yeah Amazon reviews demo space
so the goal of the event from Wednesday
to Friday is to use the free compute
from Amazon sagemaker to build to find
you a model on some data set and then
finish with some kind of project like
this so uh this is a model that's going
to predict a review scrore from a
customer review so if I Ty something
like this is a great
um uh what kind of product uh should be
rating uh ah wrong button
sorry we should get a nice score of so
does it go from zero to oneis yeah so so
these ones are actually this is based on
Amazon reviews so it goes from one to
five stars and then I mapped them to
emojis so there's five different
emojis so why is it so should so this is
pretty low so the model does not
predict the right label on this one or
how do do interpret your
label um yeah so so this is actually one
thing that's like challenging when you
have a five star system that um the the
models like may get some ambiguity um
between you know on the extremes they
will do well but on the the ones that
are sort of in between it um oh no it's
it's just called a label so it was
predicting a label that was nice it's
just that you chose Emoji about okay
it's notp putting Z to five okay yeah
yeah sure sure it's like it's like the
probability right in some sense MH so it
predicted like with 89% confident that
this was a bad review which is correct
and for the previous one it just correct
well so the goal for the the rest of the
community event would be to to build
such a space uh so fing your model liary
in caras or P Tor which is so the
general token caras ver the general
token P torch next and uh build a space
like this so once you found a project
that you like uh you should go you
should reply to the topic of the project
to say oh I want to help you build this
thing and then uh you can go um on our
Discord server uh so I think the address
is
h.
Discord uh because you'll be able to
chat with your team live there which is
going to be super helpful uh on the
forums you can
see the first top pick that you will
send this category since I have already
read it it's not appearing first for me
anymore but when you arrive the form is
going to be first for you uh this topic
is going to explain all the roles uh of
the community event uh so you should
gather to into teams of up to four
people um to create a f model and then
create a space uh this is all that's
required to get the certificate of
completion uh you have to create your
space before November 24th and the space
needs to be working one member of thef
team will double check that that space
outputs uh proper results and then every
member of the team will get the
certificate so we have created a few
ideas of project in this category and
you can create a new project by creating
a new topic yourself just like the
person I was person project I wasting
before uh and then we recommend using
fine-tuning uh for your projects like
not trying to pretrain a full model on a
new language because that would require
lots of data and lots of computes uh
which you may not have time to finish
that before the deadline of next week uh
fine-tuning an existing pran model is
going to be way faster for that and so
Amazon is sponsoring the event by
offering free compute from Wednesday to
Friday using AWS
sagemaker uh you will learn how to use
that tomorrow with the hugging face
talks that are more focused on how to do
things than more General talks are on
the longcape of
Transformers um so you will have to file
a form you just have to click here for
the link to get access to a special WS
account don't worry if you don't hear
from AWS before Wednesday because the
account only be um created on that day
and uh you should join uh the Amazon
sagemaker community
organization where because all the mod
that are pretrained PR compute need to
be there once they trained so if you
didn't register for the advant in
advance you should see a button I'm a
member but you should see a button
somewhere here to ask to join that
organization and you just have to click
on it and while accept
you uh of course you're welcome to use
your own JP us and cl provider as a
preference but that's not going to be
free and then you can as I said you can
live chat with your team members on our
Discord um
so and then if you have any question
that's more General and of to which
could benefit the whole Community you
should ask it on the main forums uh so
so that it's more visible but uh that's
pretty much it for the rest of the
event yeah and I think just one thing to
mention if you have an idea for a
project yourself you're more than
welcome to propose it so we have a list
of kind of ideas but if you have
something that you think is cool just
Chuck it in the Forum and go ahead
yeah oh and uh I see that Mark just
joined us so I'm going to remove my
screen
and so
um so our next speaker is uh Mark
Sim let me add you to the stream
Mark hi Mark hi
everyone well thank you so Mark is a
partner engineer at by torch working on
open source software production tools
including torch serve and by torch
Enterprise and Mark was also an applied
scientist and product manager at
graphcore before read Microsoft and as
CPL his primary patient is to make
program more fun and today M Mark will
explain to us how to train a model with
py
torch if you want to share the screen
Matt I can then post it and then like
before you should go on our forums to
ask your questions and I've also put the
link to the colum notebook uh for mat
talk
there all right uh thank you so much
folks for having me uh so so yeah so so
I guess like today's talk is really
going to be about like how to train a
model with PCH the hard way so I suspect
a lot of you may have seen uh some of
this content but you know rest assured
if you've never trained a model with
pytorch you'll be able to understand the
stock and if you have trained a model
with pytorch the the the talk is going
to be different enough and the take is
going to be more focused around the
internals of pie torch uh so you'll
still get to enjoy it so please stick
around and if you have any questions uh
feel free to let me know we'll be just
monitoring sh so basically this talk is
going to be about um how to train a like
a model with pytor the hard way um and
just like a bit about myself like the
the projects like I work on at pytorch
are like model inferencing tools like
Tor serve model uh like ml Ops tools
like torchx and then like long-term
support branches of P torch with P torch
Enterprise uh and if if you if you do
enjoy the stock and enjoyed uh you know
like stuff I'm saying you know go go
ahead follow me on Twitter uh and just
feel free to DM me with any questions
you have so what we're going to be doing
right now is just like really from
scrats we're going to just start off
with importing py and before we get to
training a model I just thought like uh
it'd be helpful to just discuss very
briefly like what is really machine
learning and really the the framework
we're going to be focusing on today is
called supervised learning where you can
imagine that you have like some data and
then you want a model to make a
prediction on that on that data so if
your model is a function f and then your
data is is some some variable X then the
prediction is y and and the way all of
this stuff is really going to work is
that you're going to make a prediction
but then you want to compare it to like
some labeled data so like the truth
let's call that y Prime and based on the
difference between Y and Y Prime which
is people often call the loss function
we're going to update
F and that's pretty much it so as long
as you can fit problems in this
framework you can train a model uh and
solve problems with it and in general as
a helpful heuristic when you're trying
to think about like well what is really
solvable by Machine learning uh you can
think of X as just something being that
something that can fit an Excel
spreadsheet like you know whether or or
or or like whether it's like an like or
also like an image or text but really
fundamentally it's like some data and
then there's going to be some column
that you're trying to predict and that's
your label so really though the the the
topic of of of this uh of this tutorial
is going to be how to train a model
right but before you train a model
there's lots of stuff that that you can
do so this is sort of training a model
is really sort of the last step that you
should explore so one is you could use
something like an open data set so
instead of you labeling data you can go
use something like IMDb imet or use
something from like the hugging face
data sets uh instead of train creating
and training your own model you could
use an open model what I mean by that is
you could copy a model architecture from
some famous paper on GitHub well you
know not only can you just like pick an
architecture you could also take in the
model weights so as in you don't even
train a model there'll be like a
pre-trained model with things like the
hugging face Hub or the or torch Hub
where you'll basically just have a
function itself and then make an INF
directly on it without needing to worry
about like updating it U also like lots
of like tools that make models like
libraries like Fighters easier to use
like the hugging face trining Loop like
the py lightninging loop like the ignite
Loop like the fast AI Loop or even Kos
if you're in the tensor ecosystem all
make it easier to do this and so what
we're going to do is really going to
unpack like how these trainers like
actually work and how you implement them
and draw a pytorch so like I said this
is going to be like the focus of the
stock will be how to train train a
model so fundamentally though like
before we start talking about like how
to do machine learning um a lot of these
training Loops look something like this
you'll have some sort of model and then
you want to fit it on some data right
then you have like tools like autom ml
where you don't even worry about the
model you just like fit some data and
then like pre-trained models where you
know like you just essentially fine tune
on some data so that would effectively
be like calling something like this uh
so this Loop uh so let's just show you
an example of what this looks like so
for example I'm just going to I'm going
to install Transformers here very
quickly um and what we're essentially
going to do here is we're going to use a
model by the by the Deep set AI team so
they have a mini LM model so this is a
small language model on a question
answering data
set so as you can see I'm literally just
downloading the the model here but also
downloading like a tokenizer for it so a
tokenizer is
because um essentially uh neural
networks like don't really understand
like what a sentence is right so for
example let's say we want to ask the
network a question like is Mark clear so
we want to tokenize a sentence into a
bunch of numbers that in your network
can understand uh
essentially the way this tokenization
will work this is like a word piece
tokenizer so it'll take basically every
word uh in that sentence but then what
we really want to do is return tensors
from it so we we want to make sure that
these are all basically data that the
neural network can understand and so
this is exactly what this looks like
we're going to tokenize this sentence
and we're g to basically and then we're
g to make the model do an inference on
that
sentence and essentially here the model
is going to make a whole bunch of
predictions and we want to find the most
likely prediction so we're going to do
an argmax over all the predictions and
it's going to say no Mark is not clear
actually what is my name though because
this is a yes or no model but uh so so
so so this is sort of like the general
idea behind this is that you can think
of your model as just a function on top
of some data so that takes in some data
and gives you a prediction out and so
the question will be how does how do you
train a model like this so before we
start talking about pytorch it it's
helpful to just go like you know back to
like the Titans on which like everyone
everyone stands on and that's something
like psyit learn so imagine that you
have some data and then this data is
literally just like uh on on a 2d plane
so you have the 0.11 0.12 2223 and you
want to basically fit a line on this
data uh right um so the so so so so the
question is here well you know how do
you do this and so if you want to fit a
line like one way to do this within
psych learn is to just call like linear
regression and remember fit and then so
X is the is the training data and then Y
is the are the
labels so we we train a model and then
let's say you want to get the accuracy
for it you know turns out it's it's a
perfect model but then if you actually
want to figure out like the so the quote
unquote like model weights uh this would
be like one two and then The Intercept
so this is basically the the A's right
so if you have like Y is equal to ax
plus b so a is a is a is a vector in
this case and then B is a value and so
this gives you like the function but
trying to get back to this analogy when
we were talking about like a model is
just a function in this case if you said
like for example I want to predict the
value of the 35 then this would just
here in this case like return a single
single value of 16 so again so in this
case like we have a function that takes
in like two dimensional data and returns
a onedimensional output
label um it has weights as in you know
this is one two so let's say imagine you
save those to disk and then you can load
them again and now someone else can use
this model you can deploy this model uh
so very much so like you'll notice like
in in Frameworks like
pytorch uh that you can think of like
your model as being like a data and a
function as in it's it's data when you
save it but it's a function when you're
doing an inference on top of it and this
is a very powerful framework to to think
about
it so back to talking about like
training Loops you know so here for
example in this case with psyit learn we
had this like linear regression. fit XY
uh but let's say we use a framework like
fch lightning but again like the same
idea applies to whether using dogging
face trainer ignite gas fast AI like
this same idea all applies um so we're
GNA have like some model and we'll
describe what that is in a second and
then what you're basically going to do
is call a trainer fit on a model and
some training data loader so this is
some data and then validation data
loader just to make sure that you're not
over fitting on your input
data um but it's sort of the same idea
right like model data so what's a
training data loader well a training
data loader could be something like it
so in this case it's a function that is
that applies to some data so for example
it could be like like here so let's just
go over this example so let's say you
have CSV data set or an S3 bucket or
some binary data or links to images or
whatever um you want to be able to for
example like load in a few examples at a
time so instead of just like making the
trainer take in some raw data you make
it take a function that has access to
that data but can put it in a nice
enough format for your trainer to work
with uh so there's a whole bunch of data
loaders that exist uh like a recent one
is like pyro also has a data loader that
works well with like sort of internet
data as in ns3 bucket where you're
streaming stuff uh so definitely a super
convenient uh way way of working with
data so this is how the like so here
remember so there's like to really
understand this function this trainer.
fit function there's two parts there's
the model part and then there's the
training data loader part and then
there's the fifth part right so so
actually sorry three parts so we covered
through training data loader next let's
cover the
sorry yeah next let's cover the fifth
part right so the way this works is so
remember like when we described like
machine learning in plain English like
you make a prediction with some model uh
and then after making that prediction
you want to see how different that
prediction is from the actual
example uh and then once you know what
that difference is you update your model
so this is this is going to be exactly
that so you have this first like
training step here so first off like
we're going to be iterating over like
examples uh from the data set um you're
basically gonna figure out like well uh
how different was my prediction from uh
from from the prediction of the model so
this is what the straining step is then
you're G to basic so sorry uh so so this
is just figuring out uh figuring out an
inference in the backwards step here
what you're going to do is figure out
like uh how by how much should you
change your model weights and then apply
this change in model weights here so if
this seems complicated this will make a
lot more sense when we're we're
discussing like real code like this is
just pseudo code at this point but again
in in plain English the way to think
about this is you want to figure out how
wrong your model is that's your loss you
want to figure out by how wrong each
layer is uh so that's lost backwards and
then you want to update your model so
that's optimize your dot
step so understandably so you may think
at this point like well you know like
why should I bother to really train
models from scratch like I can just use
a pre-trained model and don't have to
worry about any of this and you're right
like I mean for 90 99% of use cases like
that's definitely true but there's a few
reasons why you may want to train a
model from scratch so the first one
could be well you know if you're using a
pre-trained models and and you know
there have a whole bunch of failures
with it it'll help you debug things more
easily also you can do ml research more
easily sometimes you don't have a choice
like let's say let's say the kinds of
model or the kinds of data sets that
you're working with just don't exist and
need to do everything from scratch and
fourth it's fun you know it's it's it's
a fun skill set that can help you get
paid a lot so it's definitely like worth
worth investing more in it
um but really you should think of this
as being like over time you want to make
sure that like machine learning model
training doesn't become sort of like
this Arcane like knowledge that like
only a couple of Mages like know about
like it's actually not that tricky like
once you get to the basics of it and
hopefully this stock like makes a lot of
those points a lot more obvious to
you so great so we we've done all of
this you know this last 15 minutes was
all introduction and really you know now
we can finally start talking about P
torch so what what is pytorch like
what's the difference between pytorch
and psychic learn so the main difference
is that like pytorch is What's called
the tensor computation
Library uh with strong GPU acceleration
so tensor computation means it's not
that different from numpy but with
strong GPU acceleration is like one
distinguishing feature and the other
main feature is it it adds facilities
for tape based autograph systems and
again this is just like a very fancy way
of saying that you can take a model and
then figure out like how wrong each of
its layers are without necessarily
having to do like a whole bunch of
calculus for yourself so so this is sort
of like the main the primary benefit of
pytorch so let's go over an example
right so let's say uh so all pytorch
models need to inherit from a class
called like torch NN module and then
they'll have an init function and a
forward function uh so in the forward
function here you're going to see that
well we have this linear layer and then
what we're calling a nonlinear layer and
then a linear layer and a nonlinear
layer reason we do this is because if
you have two linear layers one after the
other they'll just collapse into a
single linear layer and if it was just a
single linear layer you know great you
end up back with linear regression so
the example we just covered so the the
main difference with deep learning is
one it adds nonlinearities and we'll
this we I'll show you in a sec like how
those work um and it so adds linearities
and then it also adds like
nonlinearities and then it has like
facilities for you to do autograd on top
of it so so you don't need to think
about how to update the weights of this
model U and if you're just wondering
like okay well what do you mean by these
linear layers and activation layers uh
the linear layers here are for example
torch and then linear and this is
literally just linear aggression example
and then torch Ru and softmax and I'll
show you in a second like what those are
in a second but you know we have this
model great compiles and then great so
so now so now we have this model here so
let me just show you what this looks
like so if you print
it right you like so so this is like
what the model looks like stere so this
is sort of the data structure that
you're working with um so you may have
heard of other kinds of layers so you
may have heard of things like attention
RNN you know recurrent neural networks
convolution neural networks but you know
they're all sort of almost like special
cases of linear layers so that's why I'm
really covering it here so attention for
example and uh so attention is really
just like includes like three linear
layers and there's like other other
better talks that that that go over like
how this works exactly recurrent neuron
networks also include linear layers and
convolutional neon networks aren't
really upfront they they don't really
look like linear layers but you can
Implement them as such and the reason
why we have different layers just to be
clear is because they have what's called
like different inductive biases as in
that's just a fancy term for they're
good at certain kinds of tasks like CNN
are good at finding like information in
the space rnn's are good at remembering
stuff attention is like I guess at this
point good at everything
um but foundationally in terms of Ops
like like thinking in terms of linear
layers will help simplify this like
quite a bit quite a bit for you you're
think about these for the first time
okay so yeah so so here we we printed a
model and you know just the thing to
keep in mind here is that really what
we're doing is very much like uh matrix
multiplication so let's just like look
at this thing like very quickly so we
have this linear layer and it's saying
okay it's taking in in features 100 so
that means it's taking in a vector
like it's it's taking in a vector of
size 100 but then it has like these
hidden features like the out features
and the in features that are higher
dimensional that way you can sort of
represent your problem using more than
just like 100 weights at the very end
you'll notice that it has like this out
features 10 as in let's say we're
predicting like one of 10 classes like
one of 10 possible animals so this is
where this shows up and the soft Max is
really just a way to pick the best like
like basically the best feature among
those 10 uh right so let's say each of
those 10 will be a number and I'll show
it to UNC and then you like want to pick
it so again the the way to think about
this is what is your input size output
size like basically the hidden feature
size is basically how much compute can
you afford how much storage can you
afford OD features is determined by your
problem like how many classes you have
and then you're going to have some
nonlinear function like the softmax that
helps you pick the most likely class uh
so just to show you like there's no
black magic here like let's say we had
the reu for example and like what does
this do right so let's say we we
generated this like random tensor this
is a very useful function in like Rand n
so it generates a random pensure of size
four and what the ru is going to do is
it's basically going to zero out all the
negative values so here you see these
two are negative so these are just going
to be zero uh and then this one remains
unchanged right so this is just like a
way of getting rid of negative values
and make sure that like your models are
more likely to converge as far as
softmax
goes uh notice here so so I said this
thing earlier that like soft Mac helps
you pick the most likely value and again
that sounds like it's a bit like black
magic but the way to think about it is
that let's say you have four possible
values for like a prediction and what
you want to do is you want them to
become a probability distribution so you
want the sum of all of those values to
be equals to one and then you would
basically generate the random number
between zero and one and pick one of
these uh and then you'll see that if you
sum them up it's actually pretty dar
close to one it's just it's floating
point numberb it's going to be hard for
them to sum up to one but this is how
you would get the max right so then
let's say you want to figure out like
which of those values do your model
predict you would do something like np.
argmax on top of the sum and it would
tell you for example that the most
likely prediction is this guy right here
so like label zero right and then label
zero could mean cat dog or whatever else
so there's another key value story that
you'd have to keep track of these
things so let's just quickly go over
like what what how these look like
exactly um so so there's this nice
Library I I like call like Rich that
shows you like how to inspect modules
and like torch functions are the same so
for example reu here you want to apply a
rectified linear unit function element
wise so this means element wise means
you're applying a function on each
element of a
tensor uh and there's like vectorized
versions there's like broadcasting
there's all this cool stuff that we can
talk about but in general like looking
at the dox is honestly really help
sometimes to figure out how something
works whereas like with dors linear the
way that works is it's saying you apply
a linear transformation to the incoming
data so you have y is equal to x a
transpose plus b so a is a is a vector
it will say how many inputs you have and
then B is some sort of bias uh just so
that you can like move around the
function and then y would be your label
in this case so again looking at softmax
here so it's saying it applies a softmax
function to an end dimensional input
tensor scaling it so that all the
elements are in the range 0 to one and
some to one
right again remember now like back to
this model right
here this tiny model that's a toy model
that we have
um remember when I said that like like
models are functions but they're also
data so let's say I want to print the
values that are like in these weights
like you can just literally print them
like this you can just say four peram
and model do parameters and you can just
like print them and like visually
inspect them to see what's going on like
maybe you have lots of nans which is
like B right but you could also like
look at for example the parameters for a
single weight so for for a single layer
so let's say I want to say four model.
params oh sorry yeah getting lost here
yeah so for model. linear one so linear
one was the first linear layer you can
also look at the BRS but any layer is
sort of the same and so again that means
you can save it you can load it and so
this is how like a lot of ml Ops gets
done and that like you train a model you
save it you load it again you can use it
for something else uh and the reason is
because like again it's it's both data
and the
function so you know like I said there's
all sorts of other architectures like
Transformers cnns or current neur
networks and you could sort of dream
your own and a great way to actually
learn pytorch is to go ahead and try to
implement one of those things like from
scratch right like and just see what
would it be like let's say so right now
we're with our hugging face H face
course so what would it look like to
implement like a really simple example
of like of an attention layer and you
could sort of do this like building it
up with with uh with linear layers but
obviously like production ready version
would include like so much more stuff
but at least it gets you like more
familiar with the
basics so other things like so let's say
we we we talked about softmax which is a
way to to to make sure that the values
in a vector all sum up to one but
there's a whole bunch of other ones for
example there's one called like a g and
then just like looking at this thing you
know you could be like okay you could
sort of try to understand like how some
of these swings work there's like the
swish function uh also the same and and
the nice thing about experimenting with
ML so back to the tiny model
here uh machine learning is inherently
like a very empirical science right so
instead of like let's say trying out a
soft Max here maybe you could try out a
g maybe you could try out a swish you
could come to the linear layer make it
bigger you could change it to CNN you
can change it to RNN so it's like very
Lego based so try things out and then
you can just see what works best on your
problem domain and if you don't have
time or don't have the expertise to do
so that's where using pre-trained models
like really really
helps all
right excellent so now like I guess it's
time to talk it like you know in a bit
more detail as to like what is a tensor
exactly so let's say we have this thing
called a so it's going to be a torch
Rand n so that means it's going to have
five elements and then they're going to
be allocated on the CPU so let's inspect
this for a second and see what's
interesting here so one you'll notice
like data has a dtype here so dtype
means it's a floating Point 32 this
could have been a floating Point 6064 as
well uh the reason I want to talk about
like d types here is because um let's
say for if you're using like Nvidia gpus
then you may use something like floating
16 if you're using like an Intel CPU you
may want to use something like int 8 so
turns out like precision as in like very
precise numbers doesn't really matter
drastically for machine learning so you
can use lower Precision bits and take
advantage of Hardware acceleration so if
you want to take advantage of that kind
of Hardware acceleration like all you
would really need to do is come in here
for example and let's say add in like
dtype uh equals like torch.
in8 uh and that's pretty much it you
know like you you like P toor takes care
of of the rest for you but there's other
also interesting stuff for example like
mkl or or so for example is it using
like the Onyx runtime environment is it
using some acceleration by Intel is it
using Vulcan uh what's the layout of the
tensor is like like is there like a
specific way it's laid out into memory
does the tensor have a name what's the
type like maybe it's a complex tensor
because you're using doing something
with music like what's the shape and
what are the actual values inside of it
so this is like the tens are sort of
like the main main dat structure that
you're going to be working with and
again just looking at its arguments will
give you a lot of ideas as to like
what's available and what you can what
you can do with
it so back to how to make an inference
though so let's say you have this
network right and now we want to print
it like again this is what this model
looks like and I want to just generate
so here it says in features is equals to
100 so I'm literally just going to
Generate random data so input to random
and then I'm going to make an inference
here and I'm going to print the output
right so this is sort of like when
you're thinking about like what is like
inference or you know just like you have
some data and you want to pass to a
model like this is the way it works and
this is how you would know like what the
input dimensions are um so that's pretty
much it right but let's say now like
well we're doing classification right so
we want to figure out like what is the
maximum value between these things so we
know okay that the largest value is this
like
1325 here and that this corres response
to index one because it's zero index uh
and this is how you can end up making a
classification from just like the super
simple prediction on Raw data uh but in
of itself you know this is not super
interesting because we just have random
model weights on some random data and we
got like you know so we have garbage
into garbage garbage out so like none of
this none of this is interesting so far
but it shows you again like how how the
framework works and now we'll do
something a bit more useful
here so remember when I talked aled
about that when you're trying to train a
model with pytorch like the things that
you need to think about are your model
so your model includes like some layers
so these could be linear layers they
could be CNN they could be rnns Etc it
includes your activation function so
like maybe it's softmax your goal which
really you can think of as being the
loss as in like I want you to for
example make these accurate like like
predictions well this formula the
categorical cross entropy like really
helps but you could have like all other
kind of formulas uh that that that you
know make more sense for your use case
and then the optimizer you can think
about it as how can you achieve your
goal so the main the most popular way is
what's called like stochastic gradient
descent but there's other algorithms
like atoms and there's a whole
literature on on optimizers and most of
the reasonable ones already exist like
in py so you can again just try them out
and see what works best for your use
case so in terms of here of an
optimization what we're going to do is
we're saying okay we want to do a
classification so that's that's why
we're using cross entropy loss and we
want to perform stochastic gradient
descent on this network basically the
netop parameters we want a learning rate
which basically tells the model like how
quickly it should update its weights so
for example if it's converging too
slowly you make this value bigger if
it's converging too quickly or if it's
too chaotic then you you make this
smaller and then a momentum is also like
slightly more advanced concept but that
also helps with like
convergence so so remember when we
talked about like pytorch here so we
said for example that you know if you
want to generate a a random tensor
that's like let's say of size two it's
going to generate two values but let's
say we want to generate a tensor of
Dimension
32 so this basically means you're going
to have like uh like three tensors that
are of Dimension two stacked one on top
of each other uh so another way to do
this could be like you know let's say
instead of it being a tensor it could
just literally be like a list right and
you just like append them one on top of
each other but the benefit of doing
things in a batched way is that like now
let's say you're you want to make three
inferences instead of like let's say
adding like a model do out on in a for
Loop you could basically make a batched
example and then you have a single
operation that can run like really fast
like on gpus so this is again where the
numpy with GPU acceleration Fitch of P
which comes
in most numerical linear algebra
libraries also come in with like a bunch
of nice stuff so let's say we have this
batch here and so this is a matrix of
size like 3x two uh and then we're going
to multiply it by a value two right but
two isn't a matrix right so so if you
said 3x two times something of size one
like that operation should fail but py
here understands like what you mean and
it what it does it'll broadcast this two
into a vector for you and then multiply
each of those elements like by two for
you because it's sort of like understood
like what you're trying to do here
um right so again like like so so so so
this is like where using a linear
algebra I really helps like where I like
you know you could use something like
python lists but you're probably gonna
have to reimplement all this nice stuff
from scratch you may not have like the
nice like GPU acceleration you're not
going to have like all the core Ops like
either an a0 or Bloss or Etc like
implemented for you and you can just
like work in python as opposed to
working like with C++ functions or
fortrend functions which is like you
know not super fun um so back to this
batch example so let's say let's say I
create an example that's like now 3x one
and then I have like let's say this is
my B batch and then my a batch was 2 by3
so because the dimensions match and the
inner Dimensions match you can multiply
these two things so one of the reasons
why gpus are so important for machine
learning is that they're very good at
taking in like these large batches and
multiplying them very quickly with
specialized kernels uh so thankfully I
mean like gpus aren't like that
expensive anymore like especially like
with something like Google collab like
all I really have to do here was come in
here click on edit notbook settings
choose the hardware accelerator as a GPU
and we were pretty much good to go um so
let's say okay so so now let's try to do
like a like more of a real use
case where let's say we have a batch
size of five and then we have 10 classes
so now like the random tenture that I'm
generating let's say again I haven't
changed my network like my network still
takes in an input size of 100 I'm going
to say okay well you know you also need
to be taking in a bat size of five so
I'm going to have five hundred size
tensors like stacked one on top of each
other I'm gonna put them on a device
called cuda so that basically pytorch
knows like okay you're going to do
something on a GPU I'm also going to say
requires gradient equals to True here uh
and then I have like my target here
which is basically going to be let's say
like the D type is going to be torch
long in this case and then I'm going to
generate like 10 number of classes I'm
going to generate like 10 random labels
uh and then the way Thor would know how
wrong I am is essentially here with this
function so like if you go back to
Criterion right so Criterion here is the
cross entropy loss right so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take the
cross entropy loss between my what my
inputs suspect and what my targets are
so basically my inputs and how wrong I
was so just a quickly sanity check and
look at some of the shapes here so so
yeah so this this may take a while let's
see here am I on
GPU maybe I should have made this
smaller let's see I ran this before
anyway like so while this runs like
let's just give it a
second okay it ran great so you'll see
here that the targets. shape for example
uh is going to be here so let's see
number of classes see targets.
shape so here the targets of shape is
going to be there's going to be batch
size many examples so basically we're
going to have like five examples that
we're predicting from right the input
shape is going to be the batch size
times the input size so 500 and in this
case you'll see the loss is actually a
number so this is a number that tells us
like how wrong we are and you may have
guessed that you ideally we want this
number to be as close to zero as
possible and this is exactly where you
know now like the the training part
really starts
so let's do this so we have this tiny
model and I'm going to send this model
to the GPU then I'm gonna have a
Criterion so I'm going to say okay I'm
going to do a classification I'm gonna
have my Optimizer I'm G to do 5,000 EPO
so basically I'm going to go over my
data 5,000
times and pretty much all pyro training
Loops look some something like this
first make sure that you basically zero
out like how wrong you were from earlier
that's what the optimiz zrad is you
calculate your current output so this is
what's called the forward propagation
you figure out how wrong you
were you get the gradients on how wrong
you
were and then you basically apply an
update to your weights and then you
start printing the loss and ideally you
want this loss to go down so let's see
if this actually
works okay for example here we're
starting with a loss of
229 where we go yeah so we started with
232 229 223 213 1.97 so you'll notice by
the way that even though we did 5,000
epochs and all we're doing is training
on a single example like basically a
single like fake example and we have a
model that has like like an hidden layer
of a thousand even then we weren't able
to get the training loss to zero so
generally doing random data helps
because it helps you debug errors before
you start working with real data and it
just goes to show you how hard some of
the stuff is and like why you should
maybe sometimes consider using a
pre-trained model or using like an open
model with like no with things that are
known to work so how would you make this
loss zero well you know maybe just try
more EPO maybe try making the hidden
layer larger maybe try adding more
hidden layers maybe try adding like
different kinds of layers and just try
stuff try stuff try stuff and eventually
you're going to find something that
works and maybe you'll learn something
new out of it so again because ml is a
very
empirical uh
discipline the faster you get that
experimenting quickly the better you're
going to get that learning what actually
works so this was as far as the training
Loop goes I'm I'm going to I'm going to
repeat it like you zero out how wrong
you were from earlier you figure out
like what is your current prediction how
wrong that current prediction is you
apply how wrong you are on did and layer
on on each of the layers you optimize
your model and then you basically print
out the loss and then I you want that to
go down so this is this Loop will serve
you well and everything will sort of
like look like this unless you're using
a training Loop then you know you
obviously won't see this because because
someone else would have done this for
you um so let's talk a bit about
gradients right like how does this magic
work right so we had this thing on
optimize your grad we had loss backwards
and we had optimize your that step and
really the point I want to make to you
is that there's no real magic to this
like as in uh instead of using the
categorical cross entropy laws like I
could have just computed the SLO myself
and then I could have seen okay well I
have the SLO it's on this device Etc um
and and even then like when you're
thinking about this Optimizer doep
function uh really the way it looks is
like this like you basically uh you go
over a bunch of
epo you figure out like basically some
gradient on a vector you apply a
learning rate and then you sort of
successively apply it over and over
again so it's an iterative algorithm um
so again like none of this is any black
magic
but let's talk about a bit about the
black magic which is really automatic
differentiation so let's assume let's
forget like the tiny model for a second
uh and let's assume that you have
something that looks like this which is
uh you have you have a let's say here so
let's say we have a tensor that's just
like 2 three and then this tensor that
has like the values like 56 and then
we're going to create a tensor so that's
basically 3 A Plus B *
a right so this is a function so before
we run this let's look at a bit about
like the calculus for it so let's say we
have 3 A Plus ba let's say you want to
derive this with respect to a then you
know you have 3 a then that's three and
then ba so then the derivative is B so
then you know that the end value is
going to be 89 but now let's say you're
deriving this with respect to B well
this is 3A is not a function of B so
it's going to be zero and then here it
would just be a so then you know great
then the value is just 23 so let's just
confirm that that's actually what PCH
does so here we're going to basically
have a place to deposit the tensor so
think of it just like as a data
structure where you're putting the
grading updates and then we're just
going to say c.
backwards and when you do that you're
going to notice okay so it's
8923 and that matches exactly like 8923
here
okay yeah so this is just it's
complaining because I'm doing it I'm
doing this twice but this is fine uh so
again like when when you're thinking
about how to use Pyers for aromatic
differentiation part of it is that like
if you have a large complicated model
Computing all the derivatives for is
really annoying to do it by hand so you
can sort of convince yourself that it
works on some simple functions but if
you have like much more complicated
what's called like computational graphs
like neural networks this is where using
an auto engine will really really be
helpful but you can always stand at
check like what are what are the deres
exactly if you look at a. grad and just
sity check them by hand to make sure
that everything works
great so once you've done this like you
you finally trained a model like success
what you could do is you could just save
it with like you can just say like net.
State tick and save it to some path uh
and then at that point it'll just be
like data that's stored on disk so you
can upload it to an S3 bucket you can
put it in an Azure blob you can send it
to your friend via email on Dropbox or
whatever and then what they could do is
they could call torch. load and load it
and then if they were to print it yeah
great like they just saw like the exact
same model that you got and then they
could again do for you know Lo for param
and loaded model. params uh and get
exact what the parameters are and then
call loaded model on an input and do it
for whatever they could call it and then
fine-tune it so again this this data as
a function Paradigm is really the one
thing you could take away from the stock
is that uh will help you really really
like gr how this stuff works
so that's really the the main thing I
want to cover today and I really want to
end like with a slightly more advanced
feature uh it's been very exciting which
is torch effects so pytorch even though
like as a user you're mostly using it
you're mostly using python but pyra is
actually mostly written in C++ because
it it it helps us like memory manage and
write things in a more efficient way in
general one exception to this is FX so
what FX is is essentially a way to write
compiler passes
over pytorch modules in Python and the
reason this is very powerful is so let's
let's go over an example here so we're
going to basically load in a model and
what we're going to do is we can you'll
see we literally have a four it's like
oh four node and graph. nodes and what
we're going to do is we're going to say
if node. Target is equal to linear. one
linear one make it linear two right so
what is this effectively let's look at
the model again so we have linear one we
have activation then we have linear two
and then we have soft Max so what we
literally did here is we skipped those
first two layers and created a new model
and now this new model we can save it we
can fine-tune it right so again this is
sort of just the tip of the iceberg but
I really wanted to show you this example
because you could do all sorts of stuff
like maybe you want to export your model
to some runtime like Tor RT or RT maybe
you want to quantize your models as in
change the D type to an in8 or 4 16
maybe you want to do something like
extract intermediate representations of
a model maybe you want to fuse two
operations so if you have two operations
that show up a lot next to each other
you can create one single operation
that's much faster and there's a whole
bunch of stuff you can dream up so this
is probably a very very fruitful area
where you can think about how to
innovate within the Pyro
ecosystem so like really in conclusion
um you know maybe in the Noto distant
future like model.fit or just like
model. fine tune will be all that you
need uh and at that point like knowledge
of how to train networks from SC like
may be lost um but you know but what I'm
really hoping is like let's say you know
like the fource The Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse like descend upon us and that
we lose all pre-trained models and that
we lose like all open data sets is that
like the knowledge of how to train like
models from scratch gets maintained that
you'll still use it that you'll still
build Innovative stuff with it um and at
this point you know you may think great
like this was uh this was maybe a great
or maybe not so great like introduction
talk is to how to use pytorch so if
you're really interested in learning
more about pytorch what I would highly
recommend is you read the docs the docs
are great probably some of the best
tutorials and the other step is reading
good code so there's lots of good code
around like whether it's by people like
Phil Wang like Ross Whitman with Maas
Fay but also highly recommend you just
check out like some of the source code
for hugging face or fast AI you'll learn
a ton about how to write like good p t
and and even then if you're thinking
great like I'm I want to do some more
advanced stuff or maybe I even want to
work at pytorch UH probably the best way
to contribute to pytorch is to solve
issues on GitHub so we have lots of
issues tagged with beginner or boot camp
tasks so you can check those out and you
can create like a cool project with this
so try to basically create something
cool to get like the attention of a pie
CH developer but really most importantly
is like follow the gradient of your
interest like as in like this is a big
field there's a lot of interesting stuff
you could do so if you do something
interesting you're much more likely to
do something else that people find
interesting and you know if if if you
have something cool and you want
feedback on it like feel free to DM me
I'm more more than happy to uh share
feedback on it um and yeah and I guess
that was it for me thank you so much
folks if you have any questions I'd love
to take
them awesome thanks a lot Mark that was
a super comprehensive tour through I'd
say almost all of ml um so great in fact
it reminded me a bit of Jeremy Howard's
uh what is torch NN really he has a
super nice tutorial in the pie torch
docs where he kind of deconstructs all
this stuff from scratch and I I sort of
saw you also channeled Richard finman at
the end um where he had a similar
analogy in physics that you know imagine
we lost all knowledge what would be the
one idea that you would like people to
remember and he was like you know matter
is made of atoms and for you it's like
know how to train neuron networks from
scratch so yeah I definely I'll say
probably metric multiplication and auto
I think those ideas would help us
rebuild significant junks of
civilization but thank you I don't think
I'm worthy of those confence but thank
you so I think we got time for like a
couple of questions um so one thing here
was um you mentioned at some point this
uh sort of kind of technical detail
about I'm not needing High Precision
bits in machine learning or maybe deep
learning in particular could you sort of
expand a little bit why is this and you
know why should I
care sure yeah so uh I mean so this is
maybe more historically but if you can
imagine like maybe the first like
scientific use cases of computers
historically uh were things that invol
were very calculus heavy so imagine like
ballistics like Nuclear simulations So
Hard science stuff and typically in hard
Sciences like the the lower Precision
bits really really matter like because
if you're off like by a bit you know
like your rocket like won't land you'll
attack someone you don't want to attack
so it's super important uh in machine
learning like just uh it's it's like I
don't know if I have a good theoretical
argument as to why this is the case like
all I can say is anecdotally if you do
try to deploy some model or train some
model with lower Precision bits they
tend to do uh you know not that much
worse than the higher Precision ones the
benefit of it though is that you're
definitely losing some performance but
you're gaining more in terms of Hardware
acceleration so like Hardware providers
will give you like better kernels to do
things really really fast so it's
definitely a conscious sacrifice that
you're taking but for a lot of people
it's worth it and it could be worth it
for a few reasons like let's say for
inference you just want your inference
to go faster because you're doing real
time so that's a great reason to use
lower Precision but even for training
like let's say you're debating between
okay I want to train for one week with
floating Point 32 or train for you know
one week with floating 16 so I'm
effectively doing twice the amount of
training you know that may be worth it
because just like time is limited on
this earth right so only rare resource
that we have and so it's just a thing to
consider so the the argument is purely
as far as I'm concerned like
but I'm sure some people that are
smarter than me know some theoretical
reason why that's the case awesome
thanks so I think we hit the time um so
thanks again once uh for for giving this
awesome talk and um thank you for
contributing to the to the co Community
event thank you thank you I really
appreciate it thank you for listening
everyone appreciate
it great so I think we have our next
speaker here I'll just add
heyob
hey cool so it's a pleasure to um
introduce our last speaker it's
yob um yakob is the co-founder of
inceptive which designs RNA molecules
for vaccines and Therapeutics using deep
learning to make RNA based medicines
more
accessible um and for those who maybe
don't know um yob was at Google for more
than a decade and he kind of knows a
little bit about Transformers uh since
he was behind the groundbreaking
attention is all you need paper um and
so we're really excited to have you here
to tell us what is maybe not so great
about Transformers we've heard all these
talks today about how Transformers are
like amazing and you know you should
just go use them and have fun and I
think here we're gonna get some kind of
cold water
maybe on
um so looking forward to it and um if
you want to stream your slides you don't
have slides right you're going to do it
in the background right exactly exactly
awesome so we'll um we'll be here and uh
I'll probably jump in at various points
when these questions please do please do
thank you for for the introductions and
and um thanks for having me um I should
also add you know um that that paper was
actually a really really fun
collaboration with a whole bunch of
people each of whom was absolutely
necessary for for this work to come out
this way um I learned a ton on the way
and I'm incredibly grateful to that that
opportunity to to work with that with
that bunch of people um but it is true
actually that um yeah I'll try to find
some cold water um I think I may have
found a little
bit um I should add as a caveat that
this is not built like an academic talk
uh so it's a bit different from from
talks that you know I gave at
conferences or so in uh that it
certainly is full of bold claims and has
absolutely guaranteed insufficient
evidence for pretty much all of them I
think um and so you know believe at your
own risk uh so so far so good um you
know people often say if it ain't broke
uh don't fix it I think it's actually an
incredibly useful often very useful
engineering um Mantra um but you know
there's a there's I think an alternative
uh sometimes or alternative mode which
is you know if it ain't broke well let's
try to break it you know um let's let's
see what's wrong with it can we find
kind of from first principles uh reasons
why you know something that isn't broken
actually doesn't seem to be broken
actually is uh is failing in certain
ways um and so maybe the subtitle to
this talk could be something like three
great reasons we should replace the
Transformer um and you know you would
have never guessed number three um and
so since this is enough uh or these are
were enough attempts uh at at making
jokes even in the first three four
slides the rest of the talk can be very
serious um but maybe taking a step back
you know let's talk briefly about this
kind of whole premature optimization
versus first principles thinking which I
think is actually uh you know premature
optimization is really what this if it
ain't broke don't fix it tries to
prevent um and I think that sometimes
this idea of first principles thinking
Elon mus talks a lot about it on and off
um you know it's potentially kind of
work around in a certain sense uh uh
preventing you from um you know doing
optimizations or going into a certain
direction that you that you wouldn't
necessarily uh have to go um and so as
an early example I actually remember one
one time uh you know as a preschooler um
you know quite a bit of stuff as a
preschooler right from experience a lot
of it some some not from experience
right but you've probably learned that
moving heavy stuff is hard um and you've
also learned the explosions are really
dangerous um and you've learned that
they look like giant Fireballs you know
not all of this is true uh and and
generally you know at least I
experienced that remote controlled cars
are F fast and awesome and then the
first time I kind of you know somebody
tried to explain to me how combustion
engines work uh there was this hits
scratching moment because what I heard
was well you
know cars are generally kind of built
around this giant hunk of metal um you
know and that giant hunk of metal is
really only there because in the middle
they're like small spaces uh in which
they're um explosions uh and they're
contained by this giant hunk of very
very heavy giant hunk of heavy metal and
and that tries to then Channel all the
force of these explosions into moving
you know an even bigger hunk of metal
that is basically uh carrying this giant
type of metal this that is the engine um
and at least at the time that seemed
like a a fairly backwards way of of
doing this obviously I had no idea about
kind of you know the the the uh the
energy in fossil fuels and and all of
that stuff but it did seem on um and I
think it's actually not that different
from the thought process that uh um you
know many many years or decades later uh
actually uh was what started this
Transformer project um because you know
we did start with a few kind of first
principles assumptions um namely maybe
most importantly that it is possible or
likely possible possible to compute good
representations of some chunks of
sequences in parallel and what inspired
us there most I guess um is really that
it seems like you know those tree
structures that linguists often talk
about when they you know try to
formalize kind of the statistical
dependencies between words and text are
actually kind of often actually kind of
largely right um so I personally believe
they're almost never exactly right um
but but often you know largely and what
that directly implies is you know if if
indeed those statistical dependencies um
are often approximately pre-structured
then it should be possible to compute
reasonable representations of you know
chunks of text for sure of sequences of
words in particular um uh in parallel
before you then you know uh uh kind of
join these parallel threads of execution
and then uh get uh you know maybe new
more Global representations from that
and another assumption we made is that
training speed is actually really really
what is most crucial for model uh
quality at the end of the day and that
the key bottleneck at the time at least
was basically the the longest the length
of the longest sequential computation
and so we kind of placed this bet that
paralyzation actually um of of these of
this kind of uh you know
subrepresentation computation uh might
be able to buy us much more than the
computational cost uh that we had to
expend in order to effectively
marginalize out the dependencies meaning
basically assume all dependencies right
so one interesting thing that this self
attention mechanism employed in every
layer in the Transformer does is it
basically actually considers all pairs
of stuff um right and so in a certain
sense you could you could say it
considers all dependencies all Poss
dependencies marginalizes those out much
more
expensive uh than than say considering
only the true one if there was such a
thing and if you knew it um but
seemingly worth it if as a result of
that you can actually massively
parallelize um so in my mind at least
that that process was pretty similar uh
kind of to to maybe what made me scratch
my head uh about cars and combustion
engines uh cars with combustion engines
uh many years prior um and and
effectively you know the the the latter
two-thirds of the stock I'm going to try
to spend on a few maybe general areas in
which I'm scratching my head about
Transformers in that same way can I buge
in please so so this is a super nice
like historical kind of context about
the origin of the Transformer
architecture and I was wondering if you
could expand a bit on the um the thing
about this first principles approach
because I would say like at least for
myself it was kind of surprising that um
you could kind of remove the sort of
somehow like temporal nature which like
as humans when we read text we tend to
read say left or right or back right to
left depending on where which language
you speak and I was just kind of curious
like was this something that you at
Google kind of figured out from like
linguists or it's like it was really
like taking a different perspective on
the problem okay so so it is a it is a
somewhat different perspective there was
a linguist involved um well actually
there probably were a few linguists
involved for me personally the linguist
that was involved most was uh was my dad
uh computational linguist so I kind of I
had no choice kind of a problem that
runs in the family in a certain sense um
and and so but but it it it wasn't just
you know what I took from him and and
and and others wasn't just the fact that
there's maybe this kind of you know
often largely approximately uh largely
approximately right tree structure but
um that in fact our ways or or this
model of thinking of language as
something that is sequential is overly
indexing on our representations of
language and so you know when we
communicate when we talk we largely say
words in sequence except you know then
we um you know often insert fillers uh
and we also you know often do this and
so forth so we interrupt ourselves the
entire time it's not exactly sequential
right we do jump back yes it's not like
we can just fill in things um but but we
try uh I think and and when when reading
text in particular we actually can jump
back and I'm not an expert on on this
stuff but as far as I know it is not
true that we always read in order so
probably I mean necessarily you can show
we read more in order than not because
we eventually end up at the end of
something right uh some long string of
of characters or words um but as far as
I know humans tend to actually jump back
and forth a lot um now that
said yes we could go by the limitations
of our own cognitive
apparatus but if we have a different one
and this makes a big difference um and
probably I should have mentioned this uh
that actually you know what we were
optimizing for wasn't software that runs
on some accelerators or or some some
some some silicon of our choosing it had
to run on the accelerators we had and
they looked you know largely like the
ones that we still have today um except
the ones today are even faster because
they're evolving so fast um but they are
just insanely good at doing these
independent simpler uh computations and
Peril and so if you really wanted to to
kind of improve utilization uh and what
you could squeeze out from from these
accelerators it just seemed to be the
right direction to improve paraly
ability so that might be different from
how you want to or from how humans have
evolved to process language um and
probably is quite different uh right um
but yeah it's just different uh Hardware
or webware that has different strengths
and weaknesses awesome thanks for the
the context and please carry on to tell
us all the problems okay okay um so
right before I get to all the problems
um I I did want to SP like spend like
maybe two more minutes or three um on on
you know why overall I personally would
think it actually helped um and and
really I think the key thing is this
computational efficiency specifically on
today's typical accelerators um but
there's another reason and that has
nothing really to do with you know the
specifics of of the model or the
architecture but really that once in a
while when something different comes
along um it helps with momentum right it
helps with competition you know friendly
and all but but still it really just
helps to to get people to contribute new
fresh ideas or or or you know yeah get
people excited about stuff even if
initially that excitement sometimes is
disbelief or so right or U you know like
I said friendly competition so it was
like that the other way around um you
know the we had um Facebook's
convolutional seekto seek paper that uh
uh you know that we in kind of in our
last what we thought last stretches of
readying attention as all you need uh
that that we first read that came out
then and that had pretty good results
and so certainly you know that that
nobody knew at the time but that
certainly uh pushed us and motivated us
and so forth and and you know I think
similar things happened afterwards um
and in terms of momentum and and and
fresh ideas and contributions that got
people excited you know Sasha Rush has
this has this amazing the annotated
Transformer post which when I saw it was
just amazing and just really really fun
to see people um do that kind of stuff
um and and I think that that actually is
often underestimated as contribution uh
to to you know kind of the community's
reaction is underestimated as a
contribution to um what kind of you know
makes this work or made this work in a
certain sense um okay so nothing else
well there's this one other thing and
that's actually that decoupling the
architecture and the parameters of the
model from what you could call maybe the
registration of the
elements um uh of of the structures that
the Transformer ingests or or or
produces actually allowed uh very easy
adaptation to uh to new and different
input and output modalities different
kinds of structures right and and
effectively what it kind of did was it
generalized this this absolutely
revolutionarily powerful seekto seek
approach to something that's maybe a bit
more like stuff to stuff right so
technically you could say oh it's it's
set to something and then or set to set
maybe even if you drop a bunch of if you
drop position representations and so
forth But ultimately if you can um
encode the topology if you wish or the
registration of these elements right
these these individual positions or as
as they were called initially uh that
the Transformer works on then you can
you can you know apply it fairly
generically not always efficiently but
fairly generically and that in turn you
know made this guy show up um and and
with them you know like this this this
hord of other
and and you know uh friends and family
of of bir uh initially I guess focused
on language really but then uh also
spilling into into vision and into this
really really impressive flurry of
activity around self-supervised uh
pre-training so there was generative
pre-training which you know also uh uses
the Transformer um in in a maybe in
quotes more traditional way um uh but
exploiting this kind of um flexibility
uh you know around the input and output
structures that need not necessarily
just be sequences in that uh sense
anymore but anything you could encode in
a set somehow um you know just broadened
uh uh the the or increased the
efficiency of of some of these
self-supervised approaches specifically
uh masked uh or mask style you know de
noising Auto encoders and and and
related approaches um and you know this
this has touched a whole range of
different applications uh including now
biochemistry so there is now a prop bird
and DNA bird and amuno bird that you
know play a role in all sorts of
different applications around or
proteomics and also provided great
sideway for me to kind of put in a
Shameless plug uh maybe speaking a
little bit to to what to some of the
things that we do at inceptive at least
which is you know as as as you heard in
the introduction earlier um we're
designing uh RNA and specifically
initially at least mRNA molecules uh
that we try to design such that they
have improved uh uh
properties in in desired ways such as
improved stability that you might not
have to Deep Freeze um mRNA based
Therapeutics or vaccines uh anymore or
that they last much longer if you do um
higher protein expression which could
render it more effective and maybe
applicable to a broader range of of
diseases and it's just a fascinating
huge search uh problem with with just
ginormous spaces you know even for the
co mRNA vaccines for instance you have
10 to the 630 synonyms uh mRNA sequences
that would actually produce the same
protein uh in our cells that we want
produce for these vaccines but it's also
an incredible predictive modeling
challenge um right we don't understand
most of these properties meaning we
don't understand how they work uh and we
don't even understand we don't even know
if we know all the mechanisms in some
cases we know we don't know all the
mechanisms uh that that kind of give
rise to these properties or that impact
them and so we have very little hope of
generating enough data in lab for each
of these properties of interest and so
really you know self-supervised
pre-training uh is is at least one of
the um one of the pieces of the puzzle
uh that we hope to be applying uh in
order to um you know tackle tackle
problems around RNA Therapeutics and
vaccines can I budge in again sorry um
so this question you mentioned about
like uh we don't really understand um
the properties of these molecules I mean
wasn't chemistry sort of solved by you
know Chemists in some sense like 100
years ago um could you maybe sort of
expand a bit on on what the challenges
are yeah sure so um uh I'll try to be
quick uh because there there's still a
lot coming but basically
um kind of true yes uh chemistry kind of
solved but
um I would say there are aspects to some
of these macro molecules some of said
the biopolymers RNA DNA um then
are not exactly kind of small molecule
chemistry in the sense that you know
just like proteins uh their their
structure their 3D structure their
arrangement in space really makes a
difference and it can affect uh chemical
properties right so depending on the
arrangement on you know the geometry
effectively of of of the bonds relative
to each other uh you seem to get
different uh Behavior Uh when it comes
to things like hydrolysis that
eventually degrades uh
these macromolecules for example um but
that's just the chemical side and and
we're definitely interested in that but
there's also the the biological side and
there it gets even crazier because you
know in in the environment of cells for
example right there are there is a is an
unknown set of players some of which we
know many of which we don't of of
enzymes of of
proteins around that effectively have
highly non-trivial effects on um uh on
the properties of of these molecules
like their their biological stability
how long they last in cells um how how
much protein they express uh and so on
and so forth so none of these properties
really are kind of a function of just
the molecule itself uh in question but
really a function of any number of of
different molecules around which I guess
also explains why you know end to end
very large scale uh deep learning um you
know has maybe seems like a you know a
worthwhile thing to try whether it's
going to work or not for say the
specific application of course we don't
know yet um there's some good
indications that it can be useful um you
know as we saw through Alpha fold and
and I guess some of the proteomics
mention models that I mentioned earlier
um but yeah I guess the proof is still
in the pudding awesome clarification
sure okay so you know with that back to
these first principles I was uh alluding
to earlier and and you know how how I
personally think the status quo might
actually be broken right now and the
first kind of cluster of issues that I
see uh revolve around data uh this is um
maybe also the most important um given
that that data seems to at the end of
the day always be the one thing you know
it's the one thing that always matters
um it's not always the only thing that
matters uh certainly uh but it
definitely machine learning is the one
thing that always matters um and I guess
I'm a good company with opinions like
this right so Thomas tweeted a little
while ago few years ago I was mostly
interested in models um over time he's
seen us interest shift to data and you
know seems like we're slowly maturing um
I I I agree um I do think it's a bit
cyclical um you know these things go
back and forth when a revolutionary
approach comes along um and and you know
promises and delivers like learning uh
massive improvements uh then you know
that that becomes for quite a while
tends to become the if it works uh like
it in this case or does in this case
becomes the area you know of of of most
or a lot of attention uh but then what
we've seen in the field a few times
already is that as uh the rewards you
reap by applying those methods and and
improving them uh start to slowly
Plateau um you know you can come back
you can usually come back to data in
order to f their approv stu um
and one interesting thing that I find
odd is um that you know we still haven't
found ways of endtoend learning from
samples from only the input or only the
output distributions so there are these
highly highly effective uh but also
pretty expensive pipeline heuristics I I
call I would call them heuristics um
like back translation or no noisy
student and lots of related methods that
effectively use learn models that are
learned on smaller amounts of labeled uh
uh data input output pairs um in order
to then turn either samples from only
the input or samples from only the
output transl uh distribution into input
output examples and sure you can do that
and it works great
um with some drawbacks but still it
doesn't seem right and there are our
architectures in fact several one in
particular I worked on together with a
bunch of people called Kermit um that
can be trained on um on on on input
examples output examples and input out
paired uh labeled examples but so far
it's not like they've actually shown
even remotely the same kind of
improvement um as as some of these in
quotes eristics and I find that pretty
odd and you know that's definitely kind
of a fairly obvious head scratcher in
the that we see this data can help but
end to end in kind of um yeah end to end
simplistic or simpler architectures uh
not pipelined um schedules or so forth
we haven't been able to to
Really uh you know reach the same
improvements from from from that data um
a slightly maybe more involved situation
that's also very common actually is that
we're still not able to learn end to end
from unaligned data and so there are
many problems out there where the vast
majority of training data machine
translation probably being the most uh
uh the most prominent um where the vast
majority of training data today actually
comes from automated was produced by
automated systems that were given
enormous amounts of input and output uh
examples but separately input and output
not
aligned but knowing that there should be
alignable uh uh Pairs and and so in
machine translation for instance uh work
that I was involved in uh back in 2008
already um more recently far improved uh
stuff um actually a variety of of papers
uh have basically proposed these
pipeline systems where you have you have
one step in which you say for instance
mind the web as a collection of
unaligned monolingual documents and you
try to identify documents that are
translated or that should be paired as
training data for translation and you do
so oftentimes using train translation
system or something quite similar um
there's also been huge progress in
unsupervised machine translation which
makes this assumption uh right that that
those links are not known but that's all
of all of those approaches are fairly
specific uh all of the ones I know of
are fairly specific um to machine
translation and and so what I haven't
seen yet and I'm confused by that is um
a generic approach that applies across
Mt but also question answering there
should be tons of questions out there
that uh are that also have answers
somewhere out there on the web that
should be Parable um and comes with
different problems uh but also shares I
think a lot of the a lot of the problems
that machine translation uh data data
mining um has image descriptions is is a
similar one there I maybe see more of a
reason for why we're in that situation
right we we've only recently started to
really use um you know training on on
otherwise unstructured uh organically
created descriptions or you know of
images all texts and and similar uh uh
in a way that really um improves over
over the state-of-the-art trained only
on on label data certainly for image
classification um and and object
detection and friends um but still it
should be possible to to to get more
data this way and and the list of
problems for which this at least I think
seems to be true uh is is is actually
quite
long um maybe again kind of a um a
specialization or or an extension well
an extension of this could be that it
need not be the case that they come from
the same from the same modality right so
so usually today labeled examples for
one task say translation for instance
right they're specific to one set or one
pair of modalities so there is now end
to end there's end to end speech to
speech translation systems and they're
textto text translation systems uh and
so on and so forth but a translation
system that gets better if you show it
or when you show it pairs of text pairs
of spoken translated sentences um pairs
of images that depict you know have half
translations in them say for instance
you take a a photo of
um a restaurant menu in one language and
then the translated version uh in
another language where where you know
instances or pairs of of in all of these
modalities actually improve one at the
same system and this is despite the fact
that Transformers have actually uh
helped along the convergence of
architectures across modalities um and I
think one of the reasons why we've not
seen this certainly not much um is that
often times these uh joining these
modalities uh in single models is done
by effectively you know adding heads um
that are then specific to those
modalities and unfortunately we haven't
yet figured out um how to how to
engineer these heads such that they only
take care of things that are specific to
the modality they're responsible for and
not of anything else and that seems to
be uh I think a remaining challenge um
that that could address kind of this
observation that we currently can't seem
to be learning uh well from from uh
examples in different modalities um or
the union of many examples from many
different modalities each um but maybe
kind of as an side to this how about
multiple instan in the single modality
right so instead of
saying um oh you know we have text text
translation Pairs and we have uh uh you
know spoken uh language spoken language
translation pairs how about we have for
some of those texts multiple different
versions right so we have maybe multiple
ways of uh phrasing the same input
sentence or the same output sentence we
have multiple ways of pronouncing a
similar input or synonymous input or
output sentence how about using that not
using all of those in uh together at the
same time um there there is some some
interesting evidence from Shin
translation and speech recognition
actually um that that this should help
quite a lot um but if you look at things
like uh computer vision problems where
it is also not uncommon that we have
many images of the same U scene or the
same object uh there it seems much less
obvious how to actually then combine
those um in in in an elegant way and I
think actually
ultimately my intuition would be that it
it hints at at an underlying more
fundamental underlying problem that I'll
try to kind of get closer to later in
the talk
um okay so we're technically already at
the time I wanted to use initially for
for just the presentation so I'll hurry
up a little bit um and and you know
maybe largely skip over this part but it
is also odd that in many problems or for
many different tasks um in computer
vision and elsewhere U but in computer
vision it's particularly pronounced
there there are probably multiple
different uh sources of data that could
be particularly informative uh for for
uh learning models for for this task um
and one crass example uh is um you know
effectively things like say object
detection where clearly you know you
today most of those models are trained
on um two-dimensional annotations well
maybe annotations also labels also in
three dimensions but from uh annotations
of two-dimensional inputs images uh or
sometimes video um but you know and plus
some sematics plus some labels uh um
along with with bounding boxes but they
don't actually ever consider um
non-semantic uh uh data describing
geometry even though it's actually
relatively cheap to obtain this right so
you know un labeled samples of Fairly
complex 3D geometri a obtained through
Light Art can actually be created at
fairly low costs and I would say
intuitively um if if a model that tries
to do object detection understands a ton
about not about semantics of objects in
the real world but about their geometry
of common objects right you know what
what do cars what's the shape cars
generally have what other the shapes
bicycles generally have that that should
help but actually so far that doesn't
seem to be something uh uh that that we
certainly not commonly do um and it also
seems like pre-training for this kind of
very orthogonal data that you want to
jointly uh uh be able to learn from
might not be quite the right
parad um and so you know maybe to sum up
the data part there's been amazing
progress around pre-training and
fine-tuning and this General Paradigm um
but transferring things across
modalities still typically involves what
I would call Franken models so these are
models where basically you know
depending on the modality you turn some
piece on and some other piece off and
you know you you basically swap out
pieces of of of the network um more or
less as deterministic functions of the
modality of your input or the modality
of your output and as a result but not
only because of this reason we're far
from able to far from being able to
utilize all the data that intuitively
would seem relevant to a given problem
say like an object detection we're not
utilizing uh um 3D geometry data um
and given that data is by far the best
overall I would say and most reliable
way to improve models that strikes me as
a bit as a bit weird and from first
principles I would say there's a lot of
potential for changing things out um
we'll get that we'll get back to this uh
at least a little bit later um but
another area is indeed still efficiency
and you know I said earlier well
Transformers improve paralyzation or
parallelizability of some of this
um some of the computation of of um
representations of pieces of your input
or or effectively your output um and
that's that's true and I think that's
that's really the the single biggest
reason uh uh why they help in in many
cases um but I actually think
potentially the biggest head the biggest
amount of the single biggest kind of
source of inefficiency if you wish uh
still largely remains to be tackled um
and so you know non agressive machine
translation made a lot of progress
diffusion models have very recently made
really impressive Lees it's actually one
of the one of the really really uh fun
things for me to to you know on occasion
uh uh look at back in in lar computer
visionland or Graphics also uh is is
what people are doing now with the
fusion models I think it's really really
cool addresses some of the you know
aesthetic uh uh issues and also
practical issues of autor regressive
models uh very very well and in fact if
it wasn't for diffus models it would
have been at least fourth and maybe a
fifth reason why we should request
Transformers um in the talk uh but yeah
then despite Global receptive fields
that these Transformers have at least
you know for many modalities we actually
know that the information stays largely
local um so there's a there's a paper by
Lena VOA and a few others that look at
representations as they evolve
throughout layers and Transformers um
and and it seems like information
doesn't travel that far even though we
have this Global receptive field where
every piece of your input or
representation your your representation
at least can talk to any other piece in
every layer and there's some practical
some obvious reasons for this or more
obvious reasons for this one is the the
omnipresence of residual connections
that provide a very strong bias in for
for uh uh keeping representations you
know roughly aligned with the locality
or the registration um say in sentences
the position of of a word uh that that
representation is computed for um but
this also means that we allocate our
compute resources approximately uniform
across this registration across say for
example if you consider images or video
SpaceTime and okay that doesn't sound
like a like a terrible idea until you
look this image and if you currently
feed this image into a CNN or a vision
Transformer it doesn't matter most of
the flops expended look at blue sky and
only a small minority of them actually
look at the bird and what kind of bird
that might be that seems wrong it seems
bad enough for this image but if you
consider a video with a non-moving
camera then this is actually true for
most of the pixels most of the time in
most of the videos approximately at
least Min Some Noise you know maybe
minute movements and so forth but
certainly for video this seems to be
uh you know a real a real source of of
inefficiency and that's simply that the
relevant information for any given task
in these modalities uh the relevant
information content is often clumpy
because that's how the world is and this
is through you know fixed resolution
fixed sampling rate so you know fixed
frames per second with a fixed
resolution it's certainly true and
sometimes much worse uh otherwise say
when you have Point clouds uh that are
distributed very non-uniformly in in in
space and space time well space
um and there have been some end to-end
approaches the perceiver is is an
interesting is an interesting one that
try to tackle this problem but so far
they don't seem to be particularly
efficient they solve some of the issues
but they don't seem to be uh to be a
real kind of complete answer to the
efficiency aspect of it
well and so to me that I can't help it
but to me this smells like compression
right the problem smells like it could
be solved by compression and so we know
that utilizing lossy compression schemes
that are actually aimed at human
perception not not machine perception uh
can help quite dramatically we've known
it for quite a while um and uh so so
could we just learn compression schemes
suitable across a variety of tasks and
you know how would they be if at all
different from today's learn
representations that that are neural
networks neural networks evolve kind of
layer by layer well one key difference
would be that they should either get
faster over time as training commences
uh or they should spread information
more uniformly as as basically as
training goes by and as as the model
gets better and I think ultimately it in
some way necessitates a change to the
way we we currently train these things
uh in part because we expect the sizes
of things to change right so if we want
to get the speed up then the input size
has to change the input shape can be
constant um uh if we want information to
spread more
uniformly uh then then again uh you know
I would I would I would say one can
argue uh that in our current kind of
fixed batching uh um uh scheme and so
forth Paradigm this can't happen
now as I prepared this talk uh and
prepared the slides and in fact this was
this just happened earlier today um um I
was looking for one particular reference
uh that that highlighted one aspect of
this problem uh and had to ask Alexa
dovitz
uh with whom I had had uh the
opportunity to work uh on on the vision
Transformer and was actually now
inceptive as well and asked him for this
reference and he didn't come back with a
reference he came back with the paper
that hit archive uh on November 3rd that
actually that I hadn't seen um uh so
much for archive sanity or Insanity that
actually for at least uh um some image
tasks uh seems to provide a a pretty
good solution but basically um you know
kind of is along these is along these
thoughts and ideas um so so yeah look
for that it's it's it's pretty it's
pretty neat I think um I haven't read it
in detail yet uh but yeah so so maybe
you know this is not one of those cases
where from first principles it's still
broken as of November 30 um okay and so
the last one that I'll have time the
last kind of block of things that I
think are are are broken um uh revolve
around symbols symbols objects you know
this this this kind of stuff and and
this is a super complex topic I'm
definitely not going to do any kind of
Justice um thankfully there are some
great reviews like the one from Claus
GFF um and and and friends but
um basically the specific kind of uh
um potential area and and currently
active area of of symbolic is uh object
uh uh Laden representations uh that I
would like to talk about shares uh one
thing with all the other kind of
instances of objects or symbolic is uh
techniques and and uh deep learning uh
namely that my overly simplistic view of
them is that they really are merely
efficiency hacks that we should learn
and that they you know don't do us any
good really um other than speeding stuff
up now this is definitely a you know
somewhat controversial opinion um but if
we look at only symbols in uh in say
input and output representations it's
not too difficult to make that claim at
least a little bit okay so so a thought
experiment right usually we represent
text for instance as a sequence of
tokens maybe down to characters or so
right but this actually comes at a
significant cost in
expressivity we we take this for granted
um but you know we certainly can
currently train text models that
understand this thing not in full at
least right
um maybe if you were to now kind of add
formatting tags and stuff like that
maybe for this case it were it would
work and maybe you know you could claim
okay fine but that seems kind of you
know unimportant super rare and
Whimsical right but then let me ask you
why is it that I can only have new
emojis once a year and why do they have
to be selected by some committee right I
we recently had this case actually uh in
practice where know there's a DNA Emoji
but there's RNA Emoji so we thought oh
can't we make the claim now that RNA is
something Mna in particular that's on
everybody's mind can't we just ask them
to get us an RNA emoji and we were about
three days too late for the deadline and
uh you know reaching out to uh to the
Unicode Consortium didn't help I
understand why and so forth but you know
there there definitely some drawbacks uh
to to uh requiring uh um uh these kinds
of you know organization um that that
stem ultimately from the fact that we we
want to use symbols to encode this stuff
and it gets pretty bad once you leave
kind of you know the the the Latin
script dominated uh uh parts and uh you
encounter that yes in fact there are
scripts to this day where proper type
setting on computers doesn't really work
Mongolian I think is an example of that
to be honest I don't know exactly how
common the phenomena are that are not
well expressed uh in in in today's type
setting systems um so I can't really
kind of estimate the the gravity of of
these issues but it's definitely the
case that we're losing out uh in terms
of our richness of representation of
things like text
um uh by using these kinds of symbols so
what if instead of doing that we
presented it you know across many tasks
in a more generic form say you know as
the pixels of an image into which we've
rendered the text and that's something
that we've actually tried from machine
translation um and and uh wrote a little
paper about uh a while ago Elman um but
obviously that's terribly inefficient
right so now instead of using these
symbols that that we hand engineer you
know like emojis like Unicode at the end
of the day um you know now we have
pixels they usually requ you need many
more pixels uh certainly if you want to
express kind of these rich formatting
and and graphical phenomena um and so
with today's Machinery that's terribly
inefficient but let's say let's assume
for a second actually had some really
efficient learned uh and compressed
implicit
representation we could potentially get
it down all the way or not all the way
but fairly close um to to kind of those
symbolic representations um and they
might actually remain richer and it's
not entirely clear that we couldn't in
some cases go below that because text
also tends to be compressible even even
losslessly and so actually you know it
seems like this idea that effectively
seems obvious for images and video might
even ultimately help with efficiency if
it's applied to text at least if you
have it in sufficiently large amounts so
to make a very long story and very very
kind of hypothetical story uh somewhat
shorter I wonder what would models look
like if we reduce the Reliance on on
external symbolic representations on on
hand design crafted symbolic
representations at least for input and
output and if we compensated for the
efficiency loss by generically or with
generically learned dense implicit
representations um and then on the way
increasingly unified use this kind
of transition to increasingly unify the
shapes of different modalities right so
we've now said that maybe images and
text should or could look very much
alike I don't know exactly what this
would look like I have some some some
guesses but they're definitely too half
big to put them even on these slides
um but you know maybe we could also
apply this to other to other modalities
as well and then maybe even this
multiple heads input and output heads
Hydra problem would go away right could
we then actually just stuff this all
into one single giant neural network not
one where you know individual pieces
have to be turned on or off depending on
what the modality is at any given moment
but where it's really just the same very
dense highly optimized uh uh
architecture same set of parameters you
might not even need elements anymore or
maybe they're always canonical right
they're kind fixed length up to a
certain degree or fixed size so anyway I
wonder what that would look like and I
actually feel like you know maybe using
at least some of these uh uh as ASP as
they all are uh observations and and you
know in quotes first principles head
scratching moments uh to to inspire
thought about um ideas around what those
models could look like uh personally
think could be could be quite
interesting awesome thanks a lot Jacob
that was super nice talk it's um it's
not it's not every day that we get to
see the kind of like deep questions you
know about Transformers being um you
know exposed this way so very nice I
think we have time for a couple of
questions um there's there's one which
is perhaps uh a little bit technical but
let's see how we go so um it's uh
there's a typo but can Transformers be
used to find which code Snippets in one
language are similar to another so you
know if you you've got Java and Python
and do you think you know graphical neur
networks would be a solution and I think
what this question is getting at is a
little bit this thing about like you
emphasized a lot machine translation and
alignment and this kind of stuff and you
know do these problems also occur when
we deal with source code super
interesting question
um so let me think basically so I would
say I mean the the simple
straightforward answer is uh yes um
Transformers could definitely be used uh
for for something like
this one interesting question is how
would you define what it means for
Snippets of code to be the same um and
and a very pragmatic definition that one
could potentially operationalize for
creating uh data around this is to run
the code and see what
happens and if you then you know end up
with either the same result or the same
behavior in quotes then maybe at some
point if that happens often enough you
want to say yeah these are reasonably
similar um and in in in the process of
doing this basically generate instances
um uh increasing numbers of instances
and instances of potentially increasing
complexity right if you start doing this
for single instructions and then you add
stuff you might even with you know
fairly unguided search procedures get to
a stage where you can just create
training data for a model uh that you
know then might look like something like
a seekto seek model but it could also
look like these um uh
um I guess what do you call them siames
or two Tower uh uh models that are
effectively uh trained to compare
different uh compare different instance
or input representations um for for
multiple instances
[Music]
um gnns in particular are basically
making use of the fact that that code is
has this has this much more stringent
structure than
uh than natural language or you know
observations of the natural world around
us I think I mean certainly in in in
many cases I could imagine could help
with efficiency would it dramatically
transform our ability to identify
whether these two things whether two
code Snippets are the same that I'm not
so sure about because ultimately whether
they're the same or not I guess doesn't
have as much to do with say their
abstract syntax trees and how those
relate to each other um you know where
the crispness of gnn's uh uh would help
as it does with the semantics of the
code um right the subtle issues are you
call two different Library functions
they're defined to be mostly the same
except for some subset of the inputs and
um and hence you ultimately have to if
you want to do it you know just from
from with zero other uh knowledge you
basically have to figure this
out ultimately I guess also made further
problematic because there are you know
many different ways of computing any one
thing and as a result even going all the
way down to executed instructions on on
on a given CPU or so or a given given
chip whatever it is uh might not
actually conclusively answer your
question unless they happen to be
exactly the same right so if they compil
to the same bite code or or the same you
know natively executed uh uh um uh
instruction sequence sure then then you
can but I don't think that's a likely
event cool and maybe one more question
yeah thanks a lot one more question
would be um you know in this sort of
landscape of of challenges you mentioned
so things with symbolic representations
loss of compression and so on which of
these do you think is like the let's say
the most important so to speak if you
had to rank somehow these problems where
which ones keep you awake at night maybe
is the other way of of putting it so I
actually think they all are I really
think that they all are not exactly but
they all are roughly different sides of
the same coin so our difficulties in
learning you know interchangeably from
different modalities you know they stem
from the fact I think uh maybe overly
simplified but I think they largely stem
from the fact that we have this this
heads problem that basically we we don't
have a neural network into which we can
actually input these efficiently uh you
know without swapping out some sets of
parameters or maybe some some kind of
structural pieces um and so that you
could address by having a a certain
sense uh a
representation um you know at a meta
level that is able to express things in
all of these modalities um and and that
you you know you could get by learning
kind of these compression schemes if you
learn them across many different models
um
and and hence you
know I
guess I also think that ultimately our
our our only way of potentially getting
rid of these symbols which which you
know yes I think they they currently you
know they are very um pragmatic uh
juristic for for improving efficiency
but we don't know how optimal they are
and they're certainly not sufficient in
order to in order to express everything
we'd like to express but I would I would
guess they're not optimally efficient
either and there again I think having
these kinds of uh yeah learned implicit
representations um is is is a reasonably
good kind of general direction for for
trying to address uh address the
potential inefficiencies but also um uh
yeah kind of broaden their or increase
their expressive uh increase the
expressive uh expressivity of of models
for some of these modalities um and so
in a certain sense I think they all kind
of belong to each other um doesn't mean
that the and it's certainly unlikely
that the easiest or kind of yeah the
most um direct uh potential solution for
addressing any single one or any single
very specific subset of these that they
would at all look you know similar to
each other that that I don't think is
the case um but you know maybe kind of
in the limit if you want to generally
solve all of these it might be that
actually they share one of the same
solution so so a sort of telling us that
you know the future may involve some
sort of you know not maybe radically
different architecture but you know some
some there is life beyond trans
Transformers in some sense I actually
think the the architectures
will increasingly uh get simpler and
simpler and simpler and they will
increasingly look um very much like I me
you'll be you'll be able to tell the
architecture from the hardware runs on
and so um ultimately I think to to me
personally um the big lesson that I
learned uh in in in the vision
Transformer uh uh work is that these
patches that we use there have nothing
to do with the
images they right they're they're not
chosen based on the image they're
they're fixed so why is it that some
patches work better than other patch
sizes and so forth It's because they
have slightly different computational
tradeoffs it has nothing to do with the
nature of the images uh as far as I can
tell um maybe in extreme cases that that
could happen you could imagine certain
distributions of images and certain kind
of patch sizes that that just make it
harder or make it easier um but but by
and large across kind of the the
universe of images and the universe of
possible patch
sizes or the space of possible patch
sizes uh what matters I think is how
well they are suited to the underlying
Arbor and so my guess is what we're
going to see is that the architectures
will look more and more boring which I
think is great uh because architecture
engineering tends to be this kind of you
know black magic alchemy that more often
doesn't work than it does um and and
ultimately I think um yeah basically
we'll use more more uniform necessarily
will necessitate more and more similar
and uniform uh
representations um that that have where
for instance also the the relation
between um representation size if you
wish and compute budget becomes much
much less direct right so right now if
you want to expend um more flops on the
same image
right take more patches of the same size
and you're going to do exactly that um
and and then that doesn't get better at
least from from our experiments that
doesn't seem to get better you know
because somehow your your additional
patches now overlapping or whatever um
add kind of more in a certain sense more
interesting detail it just gets better
because you add more flops as you would
kind of expect but that it shouldn't it
shouldn't be that kind of your
your your way of computing your initial
input representation if you want to
think about it that way is kind of the
screw that you use in order to adjust
the expended compute up or down if
anything it should be kind of how
information Rich given the task or for
the task given input um might be an
ideally you know ultimately thinking of
as humans um a little bit at least maybe
what really should necessitate how much
Compu you spend is how much time you
have if I have a ton of time to compute
the answer for a given input take the
time I
mean assuming the energy comes for free
and in a sustainable Manner and so on
and so forth but but why not take longer
but if you have to make a decision
really quickly because you know the
product calls for it in that in that
situation ideally the model is able to
at least give you a reasonable guess uh
in in much less time with much less
computer and so I feel like that's what
we should actually strive for like
anytime algorithm style
Ence you wish um anyway so yeah long
story sure I think uh architectures uh
will hopefully become less boring and
just ideally suited to to the hardware
they run on and uh you know in a certain
sense the remaining work to get us there
um is is I think in figuring out um how
to unify and uh and how to make
effective and efficient uh the
representations that we
use awesome thank you I think we've um
run out of time so thank you once again
for sharing your your deep knowledge
with us and the community and um yeah
it's been it's been a pleasure
so hope for listen hope next time we ask
you all these problems are solved well
we'll see I mean given that paper that
came that that you know I only just saw
earlier today that came out on November
3D who knows that face great thank you
very much Jakob thank you
thanks cool so the end of day thanks a
lot yeah thanks a lot for following this
event today everyone uh we have a second
live event tomorrow at the same time it
begins at 8 A.M PST and it's going to
end around noon PST with theing Team
more focused on giving you technical
talks and how to function the
Transformers model I already tou on the
flow and how to to upload the model to
the to sh the community and how to build
a space to build a nice demo out of it
and so it's mostly members of The Geek
fist team as I said as well as a guest
speaker from the AWS sagemaker team and
another speaker from the gradio team so
thanks a lot for following today and see
you
soon bye everyone see you tomorrow
bye